in the amount of time you complain about
having low self-esteem you could have
done something to build your own
self-esteem by engaging in esteemable
actions
[Music]
hey everybody Welcome to the podcast
my guest today needs very little
introduction comedians say something
that isn't true and then they prove it
Whitney Cummings is an Uber successful
stand-up comedian she's a writer she's
an actor a producer and host of the good
for you podcast you most likely know her
from one of her five hilarious stand-up
specials perhaps her sitcom entitled
Whitney or as the co-creator of Two
Broke Girls which ran on CBS for six
seasons but underappreciated under
recognized when it comes to Whitney is
her seemingly endless wisdom and endless
passion when it comes to mental health
it's taken me a long time to learn that
when you put yourself first you actually
are putting everybody else first earned
through confronting and working through
a past marked with anxiety and a
codependency disorder both of which she
Chronicles with Frank wit and humor in
her book I'm fine and other lies
people-pleasing is a form of assholery
the nice thing that I did had strings
attached Whitney is a blast it was super
fun having her hear her energy and her
humor are infectious and in a surprising
mid-episode Revelation it turns out that
we actually have way more in common than
I originally thought
so please hit that subscribe button and
I truly hope you enjoy this exploration
inside the life and the mind of a truly
unique and singular Whitney Cummings
good
foreign
[Music]
nice to have you here it's nice to meet
you thank you for doing this thanks for
having me yeah I thought maybe it might
not happen today
I'm sorry so don't apologize no life
happens this will set I I figured if
anyone would understand it would be you
that you know when people show up to
your podcast you want them to be
mentally 100 sure you're brilliant I'm a
fan of yours I didn't want to bomb this
and embarrass myself and so I had a
thing where I didn't sleep optimally
uh do you want me to explain optimal
sleep to you uh yeah I'm I'm interested
in that subject matter the reason I'm
late for your podcast is because I
listen to your podcast and I was told
you know that um you know getting a
quality of sleep in order to be optimal
is huge for me because I realize the
source of so many of the decisions I'm
not proud of or the work I'm not proud
of is I knew I was tired and I was like
I'll just White Knuckle through it when
in reality if I just slept eight hours I
could have yeah you're a big Napper too
you can do huge Napper I actually try to
break my days up into two days because I
perform at night and it's a way to trick
myself uh into thinking that the career
choice I made is actually somewhat
healthy so I try to sleep every day from
like four to five and break my day up
into two days and when you get up at
five how long does it take for you to
shake off the grogginess and feel like
you're yourself again see that that's
the problem with me if I go down like
that when I wake up I'm just like whoa I
hear that a lot do would you ever have
like a little coffee or a little tea or
something after then I would be
concerned that I wouldn't be able to
sleep when I got home at night like I
try to only drink coffee in the morning
although I'm having a little bit of
coffee right now because I'm not used to
doing podcasts this late in the day it
was just fine it's good
um but yeah I try to limit limit my
caffeine intake to the morning
interesting is there anything else that
can perk you up like sometimes if I
don't want to do tea or coffee or
something that I think is gonna sabotage
me for my night's sleep I'll sometimes
just hail uh hail the cat like what
inhale see this is on seven pad I had
eight hours I would have nailed that
word I um inhale a little bit of pine
oil sometimes clove oil and if you just
it really wakes you up oh wow I've never
heard of that there's also I was just on
Joe Rogan and of course he's got the
newest of the new uh they're like
smelling salts that are called ah
for just like consumer use not for like
waking somebody up who's like
unconscious I think that's what it's
meant for but this is meant for like to
get like a medical grade smelling salts
just for like if you need a little
pick-me-up exactly yeah and there I mean
it hurts it's like you you feel like
you're drowning for a second and then
you just have like a bunch of energy I'm
not sure if it's just the adrenaline
that it naturally triggers or the fear
that you're about to die I don't know
what right yeah I don't know if uh that
would be a high recommend you could try
it the package anything once it's like
brought to you by the guys who made the
Five Hour Energy drink shots that are in
7-Eleven the packaging would need to
yeah sort of get more sophisticated I
think what if we just both did that
right now this might go off the rails I
love it do you feel a sense of
excitement or a sense of frustration
because you are so routinized does this
feel weird or annoying no it's fine I
can I can roll with it but I mean listen
in the in the you know kind of panoply
of like dysfunctions like I have a lot
of mine line up with yours so things
like control or perfectionism and this
is the way it needs to have like all of
that kind of stuff like I've had a lot
of growth around that but still it kind
of like it creeps up like oh it's
supposed to go this way it's not going
this way you know but my ability to kind
of snap back and and you know deal with
that kind of stuff is a lot better than
it used to be totally because I think
that um it's taken me a long time to and
I've you know you know been in um a
12-step program called Alan on ACA Coda
as well
um it's taking me a long time to learn
that when you put yourself first you
actually are putting everybody else
first that is so anathema to the way
that I was wired yeah and I think most
people are but when you know you're not
taking care of yourself you haven't you
know we say in Al-Anon that if you're
upset about something and you want to
take an action that could possibly not
be a great contribution to your future
self stop halt are you hungry are you
angry are you lonely are you tired and
if you're any of those things you're not
going to be optimal your inner child is
going to be running the show and then
you're going to have shame afterwards
you know and it's going to corrode your
self-esteem so I didn't do that good of
a job why didn't I just ask to
reschedule why did I do that he didn't
want me to come on his podcast brain
dead that's so disrespectful to him you
know so for me just know that
I totally get it I'm just happy that
you're here I mean the hungry angry
lonely tired thing is also uh a core
tenet of AAA as well
um and I think about that a lot but I
think in the in the sort of codependency
parlance the idea uh there's a there's a
strain of like narcissism that runs
through it like the whole world revolves
around like you and what you're doing
and it's like oh if I cancel like he'll
be devastated or you know the world will
stop spinning on its axis like there's a
weird
um you know like there's a weird
outsized ego piece to that that you get
that gets missed until you really start
to deconstruct it well because it also
you know sometimes you just have to
parse it out you know
the I I think in metaphors a lot in
visuals that's just how my brain works
um because if I start talking too much
about something I start going why are
you using those big words like why are
you trying to impress them and then I
get my ADD takes over a little bit so
something with that you know that has
really helped me is a couple adages like
my brain really takes a corny aphorism
and just run it does very well with it
and I think that because that's a big
part of you know 12-step recovery
programs because our brains want to over
complicate everything so when someone
just distills something down of it works
if you work it and you're worth it kind
of Rhymes that stuff really works for me
yeah it's annoying but it does it's so
annoying and if you're trying to give
someone a tool like that who is not yet
in the program it just comes off
dismissive yeah you know and rude and
I'm better than you but when you're sort
of in it and really just need something
to grab onto like a refrain to almost
like you're singing a song in your head
whether it's like uh the people that
don't matter don't mind and the people
that mind that don't matter that's true
and something that is an alliteration I
don't know it just works better for me
for whatever reason but in terms of the
living out of obligation I have to go to
this thing and then I have to go to this
thing and if I don't go to this party if
this baby shower from someone I haven't
even seen in 15 years and then you also
kind of hate yourself because you don't
you know let's say you have low
self-esteem I have to go they'll be mad
at me that kind of but like it sort of
um masquerades as low self-esteem but
what you're actually saying is like if I
don't go they'll just cancel the party
right you know so which is it are you
insecure are you a malignant narcissist
well there's a weird thing I've said
this many times before at least with
alcoholics I don't know how this shows
up or presents in in a in a codependent
person but this ability to
simultaneously Harbor this sense that
you're a total piece of [ __ ] and the
most worthless person on Earth and
you're just smarter and better and than
everybody else and you can you can
simultaneously Harbor those two
identities within you so
um so those both like kind of come into
play in that thing like I've had a huge
issue with that and that goes to it
really goes to boundaries as well like
boundaries for yourself and boundaries
for other people but that idea yeah like
I have to say yes to everything
um is a big indicator of low self-esteem
but also of you know huge aggrandizement
of self so yes so it helped me when I
heard the uh sort of codependent 101 is
I'm a piece of [ __ ] in the center of the
universe right and I think that with
self-esteem is something people talk
about a lot and this is this is
something that Nettles Me quite a bit
because maybe it's just my comedian
brain Nettles Nettles
um and uh because it doesn't make me
angry it just it frustrates me when
someone is so close to having the life
they want but there's just something
that they they are perseverating about
or can't seem to
um
you know uh solve which you know to me a
big one is how do you develop
self-esteem you know and that's
something that you know I don't I don't
describe myself as someone that has or
began my life with a tremendous amount
of self-esteem but I do have a
tremendous amount of confidence so
sometimes that seems confusing to people
so when you look at someone who's really
confident it doesn't mean they have
you know a good self-esteem healthy
self-regard at all because you could
have developed that confidence because
you're so insecure that you're such a
piece of garbage that you had to you
know develop the ability to perform the
ability to contain a room the ability to
beguile people and distract people and
you know and brag about yourself and get
good at something so I had confidence
for a long time so I would conflate it
with self-esteem because I'd be like
wait a second how could I have low
self-esteem like I'm you know like
really aggressively you know I'm the
captain of my basketball team and I'm
like you know performing and I'm in
acting classes and I'm doing monologues
in front like I'm clearly not shy but in
my personal life there was this
um very corroded Soul a very low
self-worth and if we want to talk about
why we can but something I have learned
is that in the amount of time you
complain about having low self-esteem
and the amount of time you complain
about how low your self-worth is you
could have done something to build your
own self-esteem or self-worth it's about
out of steep building your own
self-esteem by engaging in esteemable
actions so if you've looked at 15 memes
today about love yourself self-worth
like I mean that I think that there's
like a big confusion about how it's
actually well because it's a verb it
only it only shows up through taking
action and and and really those actions
generally need to be on behalf of the
self so you can develop that
unconditional level of healthy
self-regard that isn't contingent upon
how good of a performer you are or you
do it selflessly on behalf of another
person and through repetition of that
type of behavior
where you get to a point where it's
habitual that's how you develop it over
time so I think the distinction between
confidence and self-esteem lies in
confidence can be you know a limited
specific skill based thing like you have
confidence as a performer but how much
of your uh
you know decision to invest yourself in
being a performer is really compensating
for your low self-esteem so you can wear
it like a mask and feel confident in
that regard but when you're when your
head hits a pillow at night you're like
yeah I did that thing but like they
probably could see through it or you
know they know that I'm not worth
anything or any like all of that starts
to but that's not your voice whose voice
is that you know it's I think to me and
I was just listening to your podcast
about the long path
um and uh mindset right yeah and
it just it made me so I was just so
excited because I've um been on this you
know uncovering like family ancestry
stuff what have I inherited what guilt
and shame isn't mine what paranoia isn't
mine what anxiety is is mine and is it
mine and what did I inherit that's
actually secretly an Incredible Gift
that made me a superhero that I should
stop complaining about and just
alchemize it into money or whatever and
I think that once I switch that mindset
of I didn't get this I didn't get this I
only focus on what I did get because the
other one didn't work for me very well
it did when I entered into a 12-step
program and started doing the steps and
writing out I remember in the amends
chapter where you write all the people
you owe amends to so in AAA it usually
looks something like I stole this guy's
car I gotta apologize I stole this guy's
drugs I have to apologize I cheated on
this girlfriend I gotta go to apologize
you know um ours are you know slightly
different RMS you know our men's are
usually like
no one owes me any apologies I hear the
ones here I don't owe anyone apologies
here's who I think owes me an apology
right that's how we go into it well
alcoholics go into it with that mindset
as well the steps are a way of
disabusing people I love that idea like
and we have because you're a victim like
I got wronged by all these people and
you know you have to like go through the
steps to understand and identify your
how you participated in all of those
things that went I got wronged by all
these people so I did the obvious thing
and started to just wrong myself right I
just codependency is different because
you're looking towards family ancestry
and when you're a child obviously you
don't have culpability for you know
however you were treated totally and
then the way that basically a couple
things that I think might just be
helpful in terms of like people saying
what is codependence because I think a
lot of people think of it as like oh
people who just spend a lot of time
together the guy and the girl who just
like won't stop hanging out you know
it's usually um to find a couple ways
that really help me number one uh the
inability ability to tolerate the
discomfort of others or perceive
discomfort of others right
I never thought of myself as a
codependent but the more I learned about
it I was like oh I'm completely you know
diagnosable as this but keep going
anyone who's not a psychopath has some
level of codependence and I think that
the one of the most powerful things that
I did was really study history that's a
really cool thing but if you want to
sort of get in touch with uh your
understanding of what your addictions
are whether it's gambling as we know
gambling doesn't always have to be with
actual chips and money uh shoplifting
what's that and alcoholism also it took
me a second to understand because I
didn't see a lot of alcohol around me
when I was a kid I because it was all
secret it was furtive you know it was in
uh different it was it a Diet Coke can
it was in a coffee cup and
um that wasn't really my experience I
would see my mom drink glasses of wine I
just thought we were Rich you know I
didn't understand what was happening I
just thought like oh at eight o'clock
like you make dinner and pour a glass of
wine and make sure she gets in bed okay
like there life was going fine fine you
know in a lot of ways but a couple other
things is that number one in order for
alcoholism to be present alcohol doesn't
have to be present so alcoholism is you
know defined by any you know engaging in
something uh despite negative
consequences right uh whether it's over
organizing
um you know cheating sex addiction love
addiction uh obsession with things being
clean and presence there was a lot in my
home a lot of neuroses about gifts for
other people we're going to a party you
have to bring a gift what can we wrap up
from around the house we can't use that
tissue paper you know I'm in recovery
because I gave you a gift today with no
tissue paper
but I see uh the healthy aspect of that
is like you you didn't have to be
perfect about it oh no yeah I thought
that was perfect right it was perfect
see yeah I was like perfectly authentic
of what it was because the old uh way
that my stinking thinking would be is to
be like I can't I have to stop by the
papyrus in store and he likes to run and
be outside so let me get him a card with
a runner on it and then I'm gonna get
the tissue paper the green to match his
chair like it was just for what Insanity
because I didn't think I was enough I
had to lead with something of value
because that's how little value I
thought I had right because you just
showing up without any of that would be
inadequate or
just get even darker I wanted you to
like me I wanted you to think I was a
nice person and I was trying to
manipulate one of the smartest people
that I look up to so a lot of it's that
that was manipulative though yes totally
can you just give me that back so I'll
take it thank you but uh so that's the
other thing about you know codependence
is that there's a little bit of a like
those people just seem like depressed
whiny boring nerds and you know whatever
so all the stuff that alcoholics do and
again let's just say with substances or
people and narcotics whatever and um
they share and they're like I've gotten
this car crashed because I was drunk
driving or uh I climbed into my
girlfriend's window because I did math
and I thought she was cheating and then
I fell off and I got arrested and then
alanon's and codependents sit in the
back of the room with like a double
winners and we're like we do that sober
right like we do all the same insane
behaviors you can't you can't get it out
or point to the substance as the excuse
well for us it's the internal drug
cabinet it's the adrenaline the cortisol
and the hit that we get from chaos so
some of it of course is going to be
epigenetic imprinting in utero whatever
chemicals that your mother was emitting
in utero was getting you addicted to
those chemicals you know the same way
you would be addicted to opioids and you
know an Appalachia if you're we're you
know in the tummy of a mother that was
taking opiates thanks Purdue
um I have umbrella insurance so I can
say that
um do you have personal liability
insurance
I don't know you might want to get it if
you have me on your show
um and um and then uh the other way what
was I
I just got just all the different ways
that codependency shows up through
neurochemically so epigenetically so
epigenetically you can come out of the
womb addicted to chaos and drama uh like
right out of the gate as if you were a
crack baby you know Mom is addicted to
crack whatever it is so even as a child
I was like subconsciously always like
trying to get on the moving escalator I
was just always trying to like getting
in the knives like whatever I could
um to get that adrenaline because
adrenaline turns into dopamine so a lot
of us don't even understand how addicted
to Adrenaline we are and how we
um put ourselves in situations that's
going to get us that hit whether it's
that toxic relationship that job we hate
it might even be being a you know fan of
a football team that sometimes wins
sometimes doesn't I love them because I
what I sometimes I'll be mad and
sometimes I'll be happy but like at
least I know I'm gonna get that hit yeah
you feel alive you feel alive and that's
the big thing when you get sober you
just think your life because you're
gonna you're gonna crunch that curve
down and you're not gonna have the high
highs and the low lows so you just think
well life's gonna suck and it really you
know basically is like a mirror for how
much were captured by those swings and
this also might be something that was a
train that left the Station 200 years
ago and it really behooved your
ancestors to behave like this and now it
just doesn't behoove you so now you just
have a bunch of tools in your toolbox
that you're using like and I think it's
just about updating your software it's
just about going from you know 1.0 to
2.0 oh I don't need these tools anymore
wait actually even though I developed
this tool to uh calm down my mom who was
screaming for example like that worked
really well it doesn't work you know
what a micro world for this other thing
if I just tweak it like I think that
when we look back at our child now go
that was trash that was a nightmare it
broke me I believe that anyone that's
grown up you know adversity dysfunction
I maybe towards the end of the podcast
can make my case of people that were
raised in quote perfect homes are the
craziest people I know
um but I'll put a pin on that come back
to it well here's the thing all my
friends that grew up in these homes that
I was so jealous of when I was a kid I
was like this is like Mayberry it's like
their mom is here their dad is here they
have like picnic blankets and stuff
40 years later they're like oh my dad
had a secret wife and Pensacola and I'm
like I did I told you I know there was a
catch too more often than not yeah
um but or you get this other form of
quote let's say just say trauma I know
it's a very trendy word right now but
that you saw a quote perfect couple that
loved each other and then so now you
can't pair bond with other people
because you're comparing it to your the
parents that you saw it was super cop
aesthetic so I do see a lot of people
who are just like I don't know I want
what my parents have it's like that's
not possible anymore that was possible
before phones and computers and Facebook
yeah but this idea of of really getting
a a broader picture of of your heritage
like back to the long path idea
um is a much healthier way of
of of thinking about your parents I mean
it's just you got to let go of the
resentment right like you got to have to
you have to you have to forgive you have
to you know sort of
step into uh a sensibility of Grace with
that and and you know that's the kind of
building block to what you just
described which is like regarding them
as you know doing the best they can and
giving you these superpowers that you
have and understanding that they were
playing out narratives and behavior
patterns that they inherited and they
were trying to do the best that they can
and it allows you to just kind of
breathe a little bit easier about the
whole thing rather than just grinding on
a resentment over and over and over
again and then perpetuating the same
unhealthy Behavior pattern time and time
again and I think a lot of people don't
understand it took me a minute too
because it was like you know didn't
really compute that
um when you have a resentment against
someone else it's like drinking poison
and waiting for the other person to do
that you're harming yourself you're
harming yourself it's actually selfish
to forgive people and the reason we
forgive people forget about but he owes
me this but he did we forgive others not
because they deserve forgiveness but
because we deserve peace and also I
think that when we don't forgive our
parents forget molestation and you know
actual crimes that were committed but
just this like I grew up in a way and I
was never taught about this and I never
got love from my dad and this and that
like
if you're not forgiving your parents I
think at this point
um you're a bully
I have such a strong that because I used
to really revolve my life around my bad
childhood it was my thing it was my
brand I could trauma bond with people I
was able to kind of control people
because they felt bad for me I was able
to blame that when I was making
irresponsible selfish childish choices
and when I realized like you really got
to call yourself out you got to tell on
yourself and what I do in my program is
a lot of like checking your motives
there's an exercise that an organization
does not Scientology but it's sort of
like a kind of a 12-step like boot camp
thing that asks everybody in the
audience on their first um
first group meeting they say like how
many of you are you're mad at your
parents and everybody raises their hands
right uh and then they go um what if I
told you that your parents only job was
to keep you alive
how'd they do and everyone's like
maybe that's too extreme but it is just
a different way to change your
perception so it's like you know an
Al-Anon you know Coda the same thing it
is a disease of perception right I have
a disease where I see things in a way
that really helped me stay calm as a
child you know my dad didn't come home
well I'm an ugly stupid idiot and I
gotta be in my report card of course
he's going to come home that worked for
me at the time so because if we say oh
my dad you know just doesn't like is
irresponsible like you a child can't
handle that sure so you have to blame
yourself because it's kind of an easy
you can control it well that was my
fault so if I just achieve more next
time he will come home and we stay and
it's not true it's doing the same thing
over and over again and expecting a
different result Insanity 101 you know
but there's a point where I think I
realized that the more responsibility I
took for my own bad choices
um uh tricky thoughts judgmental
thoughts
um uh instinct to gossip just loving it
um
the more miserable my life was like when
I decided on this like radical
accountability zero blame my life got so
much better and if you really study if
you're mad at your parents you just
don't know enough about history study
the region they came from study their
ancestors study where they came from
study all of this you know it's like and
also look at your phobias you know when
you see like people that are like you
know histrionic about worms or snakes or
bugs or stuff like that I'm kind of just
like something happens sure and you got
that somewhere you know whether it was
your great great grandfather fell off a
cliff your family's clumsy and you
should know this you know the more the
more that I steep myself in all of this
you know these these worlds the more
clear it is that almost everything
tracks back to Childhood trauma like I
had this guy Paul Conte in here recently
that episode hasn't gone up yet but like
oh you would love this guy like he's
like this you know World leading expert
on on trauma or like Gabor Mata okay
like all of these things like what gets
imprinted on you at a very early age
becomes the dictator of basically all of
your you know strengths and weaknesses
and then developing an understanding of
that to untangle the the behavior
patterns that no longer serve you
becomes like this life work you know
that that a lot of people never stumble
upon because they never reach a pain
point or an inflection point that is
dramatic enough to get them to shift so
I think a lot of people are just
operating you know in a low-grade level
of
semi-unawareness that's driving so many
of the behavior patterns that are
leading their lives astray or preventing
them from kind of you know optimizing
who they are and then I also
um I completely agree and I also see a
little bit of this
self-obsession with people's trauma
where it's like I just want to talk
about it and re-embed it well it becomes
an identity and that's its own
victimhood and I wanna I want this to
Define me I want everyone to know about
it I want to be viewed by the world as a
victim because then I can control people
it's a way you know it's a survival
mechanism to stay safe
um but for me at about five six years
ago I stopped being like overly sharing
you know with the stuff that happened to
me because I would go and then this
happened and people go oh no like and
then you get feedback from what is
entertaining to other people or aging
about other people or makes them in your
mind like you more so I find myself you
know uh really resisting sharing about
that all the time because I also think
there's a matter of like once you solve
a problem like it also you can solve
things privately and then you can do
like living amends you have to tell
everyone about everything all the time
it's a way to
um ensure that in the future we're just
making sure that when you're sharing
about it it's more about solution than
the drama of The Facts of the experience
are you just sharing it with strangers
right or are you being of service to
other people who you talking about it to
them will help them yeah but it is
empowering to talk about these things
and give voice to it which is you know
that's one of the main reasons I wanted
to have you here because you're so open
about this
um and I think it gives you know people
who are watching or listening permission
to be a little bit more reflective about
their own histories and maybe realize
there's something there that they
weren't looking at and that it's okay to
explore that and hopefully at some point
heal it and have an understanding for me
there's a there's some like you know
neurological hygiene I think that also
has been really helpful to me of you
know treating what you consume mentally
the same way you treat what you consume
um food wise you know there are certain
things that I know like if I watch this
then it's gonna kick like I just I know
how this ends and really the miracle of
doing the 12-step program work is about
being able to make choices only that are
a positive contribution to your future
self and the idea is every day I'm like
playing defense on future shame because
happiness is not a word that I just use
it doesn't work for me it puts too much
pressure on me it's too vague
um but I know that when I go to bed when
I'm doing my 10 step
um if I feel pride in the way I behaved
all day I feel good that's what
happiness is to me is pride so I will
engage in a behavior and go like am I
going to be proud of this in two days
I'm going to be proud of this text or
maybe proud of the way I behaved and
that's sort of my life hack of what I
found but then do you find yourself
rewarding yourself for that by then
indulging in something maybe you might
not be proud of you know like I'm gonna
binge this terrible show or what you
know like just I'm you know I'm talking
about like relatively benign things but
stuff that you know like as they say the
road gets narrower right so it's like
well I can't keep doing that thing
anymore or like I gave up all these
other things like do I really have to
give up this thing too yeah like let me
have a little bit of fun over here yeah
no I mean I that that I do somewhat I
really have my um I have a pretty like
rigid yet wildly flexible
um sort of schedule of things that I do
to make sure that my internal needs are
met because one of the first things I
heard was happiness is an inside job
which was
mind-blowing to me that it wasn't
everyone's job in the room to make sure
I was okay at all times even though I'm
such a people pleaser I was trying to
make sure you okay do you need anything
like ever your waitress wherever you go
but you're not really can I help you
clean up you don't really want to clean
up
is that a real offer are you just trying
to make people like you what is this
performance you know and I think that
you know codependence if I could just uh
uh jump back a little to be super
specific codependents are you know
people who Define themselves through
their ability to be productive for
others or useful to others
um we basically grew up in a situation
where we had to be precocious probably
very young It's usually the you know the
second child third fourth fifth someone
that had to raise themselves someone had
to be you know too mature too early so
then they have an over developed
responsibility as adults to other people
so a lot of it is like before you solve
the problem first make sure it's your
problem you know that's a trick you want
you know and then you look at your
motives for whatever you're doing I'm
going to this
yeah a bachelor party I really want to
go to this am I doing this out of
obligation if I'm doing this out of
obligation that's gross to do to the
other person because anyone that is
truly a friend of mine um we have an
authentic actual intimate connection you
know as friends I'm lying my behavior is
showing up in line we really focus not
on what we say it's about the choices we
make in the behavior we make so I would
never want someone that I'm friends with
that come to something out of obligation
and be like oh God why am I going oh
yeah like I would never want that that
would you know so that's gross and
that's all between you and your you know
a spirit you know because I think that's
what slowly breaks our spirit when we
force ourselves to do things that we
don't want to do because we assume that
those P we project onto them you're
going to be as punishing as my this
person you're going to be as mean as
this person you're going to keep score
like this other it has nothing to do
with that person right um and your world
view is that everything is conditional
in your life everything has everything
is teetering on disaster at all times
unless you like sort of do that right
Behavior but that's us and that's it's
your job to heal yourself I know that's
that that is my as soon as I started
thinking that way and as soon as I
started saying like why doesn't someone
just invent a time machine to change my
childhood like what did I think was
going to happen you know I think you get
to a point where you're like I've tried
all these things blame just doesn't work
Obsession doesn't work silently seething
doesn't work complaining all day doesn't
work you know let me just try this whole
you know grant me the serenity accept
the things I cannot change the courage
to change and the wisdom to know the
difference so there's a lot of things I
have power over like but I remember
early on in a um
a meeting
a woman talked about how when she's not
clear on what is and isn't her
responsibility you know um because
codependents we tend to be the people
that are like what do you need I need a
doctor let's call Whitney oh what's that
Dennis called I like love to be useful
want to entrench myself in your life
because ultimately
you'll abandon me so I have to find ways
to put my hooks in you you know and
being helpful and useful it's like I've
got your insulin where are you gonna go
you know is kind of all of it is fear of
being abandoned and it all came with a
scorecard you know I dropped off flowers
for your wife and then I brought you
this thing for your kids you didn't ask
for any of that and then my birthday
comes up and Rich doesn't I went
you're the only one keeping score though
but yeah 100 and then I'm destroying my
relationship with you because I did a
bunch of nice nice people pleasing as a
form of assholery the nice thing that I
did had strings attached you know but
today I had no you know because I didn't
pay for it or buy it for you I don't
know I did the least you know and that's
sometimes how you keep a relationship
strong and your connection to yourself
because you're also betraying yourself
you're lying to yourself and you're
performing and I found that I got to a
point in my life where someone asked me
a sponsor I was working with said um
when you look in the mirror do you look
in your eyes
and I was like such a weird ass L.A
sciental what is it like am I getting a
pamphlet like and I realized I look in
the mirror and I just and the fur never
never never because I was so
disconnected to myself because I was
betraying myself you know all day long
and um lying to other people myself with
my actions my behaviors guilt-based
decisions
um mothering martyring micromanaging
which those are the three M's which is
you know it could be fathering
micromanaging martyring whatever it is
it's just basically you're constantly
trying to rescue people help people fix
people's solve problems that aren't
yours with your overdeveloped sense of
responsibility and I remember
I just was like yeah I'm everyone's
assistant or I'm it's my job to fix
everyone save everyone which is part of
the reason that al-anon's you know
whereas an alcoholic might be addicted
to alcohol and alcohol might be addicted
to the chaos created by that alcohol I
feel like we need new terminology
because when you say alcoholism you
immediately think of alcohol you said
earlier like you don't need alcohol
present for alcoholic Behavior but
to your point like it's not about
alcohol like it needs a new term I mean
maybe just Addiction in general right
and you know and like Al-Anon and
codependency is generally thought of in
this reductive sense of of enabling
alcoholic Behavior which is essentially
when something stops being a choice
right like that's a that's a definition
that really works for me whether it's
you're masturbating at work in the
bathroom or you're working on your
computer till one in the morning and
then it's two and you're if you or
whatever your behaviors any of them when
it stops being a choice is right to find
it as an addiction I think I'm just a
little bit sensitive to I would love to
know what you think um
because the addiction to the phone the
addiction to the Snapchat all the stuff
that's alcoholism you know on some level
but it is masquerading as something else
because and then once you get it's
whack-a-mole right once you get the
drinking under the control the eating
comes up once the eating comes up the
sex comes up once the sex go down the
porn comes whatever addicts just I guess
has been used for so long as a negative
term and I believe that addicts have
superpowers that a lot of people don't
and are usually hyper Vigilant
um
just very smart you can't get away with
your alcoholic Behavior if you're not
wildly smart you know you have to be
crafty and cagey to perpetuate that
behavior over a long period of time but
I think yeah I think that that there's
it's certainly not a referendum on
intelligence like it it applies equally
to everybody no matter how you were
brought up or who you are and my whole
thing with addiction is that it lives on
this massive Spectrum so we think of it
as alcoholism or drug addiction or
gambling we have these little buckets
for it but I think you know movies like
The Social dilemma and the relationship
that the the sort of fraught
relationship that we all have with our
phones now is making people realize like
oh we're all captive on some level and
we all sit somewhere along this spectrum
and maybe it doesn't interfere with your
life that much for a certain sector of
the population and then way over here
you know you're living on skid row and
you can't you know like it's but I think
a lot of us sit somewhere you know in
the middle and you know whether it's I
can't put my phone down I can't stop
rolling or you know as soon as I get
activated by a text or an email I have
to respond immediately or I keep getting
I keep dating the same kind of person
and having the same kind of result like
all of these things are you know
alcoholic slash addictive behaviors and
the more that we can become self-aware
of what's driving us and where it's
leading us I think we're in a better
position to you know heal those wounds
and find better strategies for life so
it's really a it's a very uh you know
Universal condition I think and that's
kind of the drum that I'm always banging
with this and maybe it's just me because
I've spent so much time in with family
members in rehab and sponsoring people
and stuff and and maybe this is just the
people that decide to go to the meetings
and reach out you know and I'm always
like I always start with this person
might just be too damn smart to get this
yeah intelligence does not serve you in
recovery and most of the addicts if
we're gonna say that for now I say
superheroes
um or uh you know whenever I meet them
I'm like oh you were just smarter than
everyone that's why you didn't feel
understood you're just more sensitive
than ever you just have all these
superpowers and you wanted to dull
yourself you wanted to check out of your
own brain you know is usually so when
I'm working with someone new a sponsor
or something it's something like it's
almost like you've been over developed
with uh you know certain things and some
people just you know the way that I
think it was Margaret Cho was just on my
podcast and I was reading about her
um when she went into rehab she said
something so perfect that made me just
fall in love and relate to anyone that's
ever used substances to to dull their
brains she's like I just didn't want to
care anymore I just wanted to stop
caring for like a day you know I just
want to stop caring about what people
thought about me well that's where the
The Addictive Behavior is the solution
of the problem it's not the problem it's
the solution and it works or we wouldn't
do it but then at some point it stops
working right and we keep doing it
that's the problem so in relationships
whether it's drug addiction or
codependence or Al-Anon It's tricky
because you know your problem uh your
problem is you and the fact that you
gravitated towards this you know
situation and found it to you thought
this person was your soul mate because
they were giving you all this chaos and
drama or this person is such a mess in
their life that it makes me feel
Superior even though I'm I'm just less
of a mess than the person in active
addiction you know so it gives you like
you know this arrogance of like he
doesn't even know I have to go learn
Spanish to talk to the drug dealers I
guess I'm just a hero Angel
um right and that's what you needed to
you know to kind of sell that wound that
you have inside I just got high off
self-righteous indignation thank you
person and active addiction I just used
you to get my hit right you know so it's
just this really toxic you know
surreptitious it's it's a Al-Anon is
very Insidious because a lot of it
masquerades as kindness you know when I
was in the throes of my codependent
Behavior if someone asks you what's
Whitney like she's the nicest she drives
everyone to the airport that she doesn't
even know like it you would go that
sounds sick you know but
it nice you know it's pathological
kindness we like to say pathological
thoughtfulness as a way to let you know
how thoughtful I am right
prophets Walk Among Us
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10
years I've become more convinced than
ever that our world is populated by
scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share those
that we don't know who can teach us
something new and leave us all the
better for the experience of their
sharing
and so I've dedicated my career to
tracking down the most compelling
profits on the planet going deep with
each of them on my podcast to elucidate
the best of what they have to offer and
to sharing the insights gleaned for the
benefit of all
but the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories which is
why I'm proud to announce the release of
my new book voicing change volume 2.
more than mere words on paper voicing
change is a physical manifestation of
the magic
inspiration and Timeless wisdom that
transpires each week on the ritual
podcast
the first edition of voicing change was
a beautifully rendered book worthy of
display on any coffee table
and volume 2 follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite
conversations in an elegant publication
replete with interview excerpts essays
and stunning photography making for an
Exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying Standalone work
picking up this book allows you to
revisit the wisdom of your favorite
everyday profits and physically interact
with the life-changing ideas contained
with that
voicing change volume 2 available now
while supplies last for a limited time
order your copy today only at
richroll.com
so what was your Breaking Point with all
of this like how did how did you get
ushered into the rooms
I had a family member go into rehab
um because also I the the Wild Thing
probably very similar to work addiction
is that codependence is incredibly
rewarded it is incredibly rewarded you
are so useful I played Sports really
competitive competitively I was always
the first person to get there the last
person to leave like I was hello yeah
totally just mostly because you guys
organized this wrong
you know we think we're right about
everything because we had an alcoholic
coach who was less reliable to make it
to mornings from practice so I had the
keys
to the pool
and that is a form of trauma that most
people wouldn't categorize under trauma
but it was like and I was proud I was
like yeah I'm reliable I will be there I
will make sure that everybody gets in
we're going to have mornings from
practice which goes oh the authority
figure isn't reliable
I'm on my own you know so as soon as and
that drives the control issues and the
perfectionism because you have great
data that you should have the keys you
know that's the tricky part is like your
mother and you're micromanaging well you
guys suck at this I like there's also a
tricky one because like well I am better
at this than you are maybe not for the
right reasons but I am you know so then
you get to a point where you just go
it's not about that you know and then
when you're leading 200 people there's
no time to act like that and turns out
when you think that you're helping
someone or helping them save time you're
just patronizing them and you're like
telling them I don't trust that you can
do this so I'm gonna do it myself but
the guy says oh you know I'll do it for
you oh I got it no no I got it no
worries you go home but you're really
just saying I don't like the way you do
things I'll just murder myself and do it
and then start to hate you and not even
give you a chance frankly right you know
because we were proven wrong as a kid it
was very hard to trust other people to
do things I had a um a really brutal uh
uh a family member of mine went into
rehab and I was you know they there 24 7
did the intervention bring in the
nutri-grain bars bring in the you know
athletic greens you know just there
every single day what do you need can I
get you a sweatshirt do you need do you
need new shoes do you need comforter I
mean I was just there all day every day
while I was doing two television shows
simultaneously and um
someone pulled me aside uh my now
therapist
um who was the family uh therapist there
she specializes in Neuroscience of
addiction childhood trauma etc etc and
she um she started your sober she's
missing and she came up to me and she
was just like hey so
you know you're just killing this person
faster
um
and I was like you know but
and of course I had guilts about what
happened to both of us as kids you know
what happened to her not and I just
wanted to fix it with my love and that's
not how neurology works that's not how
younger than you older older interesting
you know and so we both have sexual
abuse in our past which is a very once
you really get a handle on that a lot of
behavior starts to make sense and you
start to go oh wait a second all these
things I do I could actually kind of
like reroute to be incredible tools to
give me a giant Advantage like I
actually think I have a giant Advantage
because of all these things like let me
just perceive it that way you know so
for the longest time I perceived my
trauma as exactly what it was the trauma
I didn't block out which we can talk
about later or repressed or completely
disassociate from but I perceived it as
trauma and as a liability and I have two
broken legs and a broken brain and then
as soon as I change my perception on it
I was like oh my God I was like gifted
all these wild superpowers I'm just
using them wrong you know so once I was
able to do that I it my life got pretty
awesome but it took you know 14 years in
Al-Anon and right still sponsoring and
still super involved so when that
therapist was like you're killing
yourself
uh or you're you're actually killing
this person that you love more quickly
because you're not giving them the
Dignity of their own experience and you
can't grow if you do everything well and
you're slowly killing yourself trying to
solve a problem that's not your problem
to solve right but when that lands like
a ton of bricks like does that ring a
bell in you and say I need to go to
Al-Anon or like how did you like walk
into your first meeting well because
then the first thing I did was I went to
the person I was like am I killing you
like is this bad should I not give you a
hundred dollars every day for whatever
you need for groceries yeah but you're
you're asking the unreliable narrator
like of course they're gonna say keep
doing it the drug addict need cash in
rehab yeah so I did the you know
Cardinal mistake which I went back to to
the person and I was like I just talked
to her and she she doesn't she thinks
it's fine when I'm doing like and she
was like okay so
that's hilarious I make I'm like I'm a
hero and I get I don't think you
understand okay like I'm handling this
I've got it and um
she said to me she goes you know there's
a program uh that you know is worth
going to I'd love to take you some time
and you know I was like why why would I
need a program she's the one that won't
stop drinking right come from the same
household Cut From the Same Cloth had
the birth order been reversed it would
have just you know and she goes well I
just watched you go to the problem for
the solution
and I was like yeah that's how you get a
solution like I was like you sober
people are just
you don't get it you know I mean I saved
I'm very busy person I don't so her
whole thing was like no if you have a PR
if your problem is someone else's
Behavior you go to a program to for the
solution because the solution might be
do nothing
the solution might be do not a damn
thing because we're so addicted to
taking an act that doesn't compute does
not compute so then I was like okay I'm
gonna go to this meeting so I can figure
out how to get her so
hahaha
well that that's that's the equivalent
of like I'm gonna go to a so I can
figure out how to continue to drink
without being an alcoholic
or people that are like I shoplift that
but I'm just going to the gambling um
12-step programs because it's basically
a gambling addiction at the base of it
it's like well you're not okay but yes
The Lies We Tell ourselves and the
delusions and look I had a ton of proof
that I was a super high function as a
perfectionist as a micromanager and as a
martyr I had gotten a lot makes it
harder because the world is smiling upon
you and you're being wildly rewarded for
these unhealthy Behavior patterns that
you're blindly unaware at some point are
really going to derail you at best and
might actually kill you sometimes we're
hurting people in ourselves and we don't
even know it because we're just zombies
and it always worked for us before and I
went in to my first
um 12-step Al-Anon meeting ACA adult
child of Alcoholics is the focus which
basically means you grow up in a home
with addiction let's say
um to anything and I went in and I was
so bored I was like these people I now
look back and I can say oh my God all
these people actually had self-worth and
self-care and that's why they were doing
these things like this guy's eating a
salad like why are you in pajamas like I
was just like what is this I was like
this is like a bunch of slobs
complaining you know and um and then
there were all the rules and I was like
God how dumb are these people that you
have to sit through all these rules and
everything like wait can we just get to
it and then every time someone would
speak where that it didn't apply to me I
would just like
tune out or like get on my phone looking
for the differences totally I was oh I
was like oh no no if you guys aren't
only talking about me like I'm at it was
just and then they I was like okay I get
it I did get it in that meeting because
someone said people pleasing is a form
of assholery
uh that clicked and then the speaker
that day opened with I have good news
and bad news the good news is the war is
over the bad news is that you lost
so now it's just about
like that's great news the Damocles
sword foul now let's just pick up the
pieces you know and that to me was like
I know how to do that being in delusion
about whether something is going well or
bad that is confusing to me because I
can convince myself of anything you know
I think that helps me as a comedian to
be able to see both sides of everything
and empathize with you know every uh
facet of something but I heard that and
I was like okay and then I went to
another meeting and also that was enough
to get you to go back well also you know
uh it was hilarious
and there were these deep belly laughs
that I had never experienced or were you
thinking like I can get some good
material here it wasn't even that it was
a very Hollywood way and I kind of like
I love that people think I'm so
Hollywood I live right down the street
no but I know I know but like did you go
like when I got sober the all the
meetings I went to were Sundowners yeah
of course like I've been to all of them
that's where I went to try and date
musicians yeah it's good for that
oh I'm aware yeah Melrose in Mansfield
um Log Cabin sure that's where I got
sober and I was there every morning for
years I must say you know thank God this
podcast exists so people can hear this
everywhere but Southern California is an
incredible incredible for Recovery true
I'm so grateful like the community of
people that I was able I mean I needed
all new friends right and I was in a
city where there were just tons of young
cool people who were sober and really
into recovery and would like love going
to meetings and it was unbelievable like
my first couple years of just going from
meeting to meeting to meeting and
meeting all of these amazing people
who've become like my closest friends by
the way amazing people people are always
like a meeting like an mature abandoned
church I'm like which a lot of people
have God stuff you know of like God
what's this so I usually will go with
people with their first meeting because
I'm like the God thing just don't worry
about it like it's just not God just all
you need to believe in this is that you
aren't God
do you know what I'm saying if you
cannot say that you're not God and you
can't change people not don't forget
about the word god altogether and you
know use higher power or whatever you
want and just think well this group of
people has more power than me because
they figured out something that like I
have trouble figuring out and why are
you looking so badly for an excuse to
not do this that's the key just look at
that the god thing's weird that's the
saying you're that is your opinion I
mean so it's sort of that's the main
thing for most people that prevents them
from walking through the door and
everybody has all of these preconceived
ideas about what it is and what it isn't
and a lot of that is driven by media
what they've seen in movies and
television or some family member that
wasn't able to get sober through the
program or whatever which is why I have
like I mean I'm interested in your
perspective on this like what is your
relationship as a public person with
respect to the tradition of anonymity
and how you talk about this kind of
stuff because we've been talking about
this for an hour right and like I am
always battling with that a little bit
because had I known what I discovered
when I came into the meeting I might
have come in earlier and I understand
the importance of anonymity and I would
never divulge you know the specifics of
who was there or what was said but I can
still evangelize the benefits of it
generally and I I think that that is a
net positive although I'm never sure
kind of where that line is because I
want to encourage people who are
struggling to check it out right and to
do that you have to you know sort of
characterize it as as something
aspirational
may I ask for a pen and a piece of paper
not just something because I'm my brain
is like I'm actually listening to you
that doesn't happen a lot and so I'm
listening and then I'm like wait what
was that thing I was gonna say
um
I love this question I love this
question especially because I just felt
myself getting a little defensive
which is so obviously this is something
I've been kind of grappling with in some
way even if I haven't talked about it
much because there is you know in these
programs and Alan on the ideas you
always keep the person Anonymous always
always always not only because it's no
one's business who it is and doesn't
matter but also it could put the person
that is in that program in a lot of
danger if you you know you're not
allowed to call and leave messages or
voicemails on someone else's voicemail
machine and be like hey is your
alcoholic husband still beating you
because they could hear that and you
know it could put the person in danger
so that is a lot of the the anonymity
stuff also you know clearly in public
you don't want people to know anything
you're doing in private that's not fair
so I would never
um out someone else's anonymity but I
think for me personally and
um I think that the leaders of the day
need to make sure that things that
leaders from 50 years ago
decided was a great rule that we just
like keep looking at them and go is that
still the case is that still the case
because you know we've got things like
um kids shooting up schools and we've
got a real mental illness crisis should
we still keep this secret is it still I
for me I'm a little bit Reckless and I
also I just I just don't lie that's
something that works for me and I think
that
if anyone was struggling the way I was
struggling
to not talk about this program which is
also free medicine in a country where
there's just not any free medicine
um let's you know to be frank like it's
kind of a [ __ ] miracle that it exists
and it thrives and it helps so many
people and it's free and it's full of
people like where else in the world can
you walk into a room totally broken and
have a community of people come to your
Aid and help you and not want anything
in return It's [ __ ] amazing there's
also so sorry go ahead no let's just say
there's just all nothing more healing in
general I encourage ever I mean I'm not
trying to tell everyone like hey you're
all uh you all qualify for this it's a
self-diagnosed disease but we all come
from this you know we all come from if
you again read history books you know we
we're a hundred years behind us was
Prohibition I mean they had to outlaw
alcohol in this country I know there's
the real sad story so black people
probably couldn't vote as much you know
there's a lot of sketches that's a
different podcast that's a different
podcast that I'm not gonna weigh in on
but there's a lot of sketchy reasons
that prohibition happened obviously but
you know alcoholism in this country and
you know in the countries we immigrated
from were just a very I mean my I looked
into my ancestry to try to solve some
problems or um unearth some sort of
engines in me that I
didn't uh aren't relevant to my current
life and um I have half my ancestors
died of cirrhosis you know I mean this
is not new you know so I think that to
not talk about this is like you're not
talking about history you're not talking
about science you're not talking about
epigenetics there's just no way
um to not to try to be in the space in
any capacity
um and not talk about it and yes it's
it's a bunch of people who want to be
more mature it's a bunch of people that
want to make right decisions and I think
that if you only look at the data from
being on the internet where Everyone's
an [ __ ] and everyone wants to cancel
everyone you do need to make sure if
you're gonna engage and consume that
stuff online what is your antidote to
that to make sure that you're seeing the
world and human beings in a balanced way
I'm very lucky I have stand-up comedy
because I get to go see you know 2 000
people in one room they're all laughing
at the same [ __ ] no one knows what
anyone voted no one knows you know what
team anyone roots for I'm like we have
so people are trying there's these
people laughed at these jokes and they
left and they want to vote none of them
were like you're punching like most
people aren't like that and I think that
if you want to be mentally healthy today
you have to take active contrary actions
to make sure that you're getting data
from in interactions from most people
not just the like 10 000 people online
who are probably very mentally ill yeah
yeah yeah
I mean I think the argument in terms of
anonymity I mean the the kind of actual
languages were were Anonymous at the
level of press radio and film right
that's kind of like in the in the
literature okay you didn't put YouTube
in there Bill I know but like is this
press is this well it's not technically
radio right I know but but I guess you
could make the argument I mean the idea
of being like you don't like you know
promote this in the world and and part
of that is if you're a public-facing
person and you do that and then you
relapse it reflects poorly on the
community and I think there's some I I
understand that look you know Bill the
big book doesn't include phones cell
phones it doesn't include computers it
doesn't that was written before like
porn and Vapes and weed being legal
there's a couple things that need to be
updated about it and you know I'm happy
to be wrong but I usually feel like I'm
going in the right direction when I'm
able to stop and check my motives and go
okay am I talking about this to try to
get attention am I talking about this to
try to make people feel sorry for me am
I trying to make people like me am I
trying to make people think I'm smart
what am I trying to do and then if I'm
like no I just I am I if I had had this
program
when I was 20 a program to re-parent
myself that's all it is our parents said
the best they can with the tools they
had and then there's just it's just
college for how to behave in
relationships how to behave
um how to treat yourself how to treat
other people I just didn't I got a bad
blueprint for that and it was no one's
fault I mean my dad and mom worked a lot
they were really busy you know because
they had to work for money I interpreted
it as neglect right but they were trying
to keep me fed you know I was a
perception issue and so there's so many
magic tricks in this program there's
also just some of the most incredible
people I've ever met some of the most
healing laughs I've ever had because
there is a levity Within These programs
no one wants to have to do that three
times a week you know until then once
you start doing it you really want to do
it because you know how great it is it's
like exercise or anything it's gonna
suck for the first couple weeks and then
you'll get kind of addicted to it and I
think there's such a thing as positive
addictions if you know your brain is you
know
you know doesn't hold dopamine the same
way other people sold dopamine which is
basically what ours is there's
biological bases for it you know
um but then when you start getting
addicted to meetings and hanging out
with friends and cool people and taking
calls from sponsees you know you're like
wait is this addictive the way you're
like no this is a good thing like this
is a positive addiction yeah yeah yeah
yeah I I totally agree I mean I think
that there's
you know on the on the subject of levity
like there's nothing more healing than
to go into that environment harboring
some deep shame or some secret about
some terrible thing that you did and
hear somebody share a similar analogous
version of that story and just own it
with laughter it's just unbelievably
liberating to realize like oh hey I'm
not alone and B like there is hope to
transcend this thing that I'm so deeply
afraid of ever telling anybody that that
I did and the fact that there's people
around there who will you know welcome
you without judgment and walk you
through the process of going from the
newcomer to being the person up there
sharing your story is just the one of
the coolest things I've ever
participated in or been witnessed to and
um in addition when someone is helping
you you're helping them so you don't
have to feel guilt at all this person's
helping me and you know that's the mind
[ __ ] that like took me a long time to
figure out but yeah that's the mind [ __ ]
of codependents in general because
normally codependents I'm like just call
me every day well you mean it's good for
me to be of service to people like I can
selfishly be of service because it will
help me like that's probably not a great
message for her and Al-Anon well no it's
more that I'll go okay great I'll
sponsor you let's talk every morning for
10 minutes talk every night for 10
minutes send me this many voice memos a
day anytime you do this or this just
check in with me about it let's make a
scout whatever and it's a lot of like
well I just I don't want to bother you
like I just don't wanna I know you're
busy and like I just don't I feel guilty
calling twice a day and I'm like so this
is the you know mind [ __ ] of
codependence so uh let's play that scene
out I'm you're the uh codependent you're
a newcomer day one into Al-Anon um Rich
I'm your sponsor I want you to call me
twice a day check in
yeah well I don't know like I don't want
to bug you
so I don't I don't know so I'm busy
you're busy
yeah
but if it was if we stopped before that
time it was this but it's more like I
don't want to bother you so I said call
me you said I don't want to bother you
so now you're calling me a liar hmm
you're saying that I just said something
insincere
mm-hmm
that's rude
you know what I'm saying yeah so it's
like when we really get to the bottom of
codependent I'm so worried about you
you're saying a couple things number one
that I'm bad at my own time management
that I say things that I don't mean and
that I'm trying to manipulate you like
you doing that was insulting to me right
well the other piece at least from the
alcoholic perspective in that context
would be what's your angle or what are
you trying to get over on me or you're
trying to like there's a hitch here
waiting for you know like for the for to
find out like oh you're actually trying
to run a scam on what I would say is
good news bad news
the shoe dropped
I'm not gonna [ __ ] you over you already
[ __ ] yourself over now you know what I
mean like what would I [ __ ] you over for
your three DUI you don't have anything
that I want dude that's the thing why
would I what what do I get you're stupid
that's the grandiosity of the newcomer
right and then also you can get
information just so I think a lot of
what this is about is just like slowing
down the way that we talk and getting
super granular with what your reaction
is to something so if I stayed a nice
Ponce I sponsor you know female
identifying people
um uh I say uh call me anytime she says
I can't I feel guilty and I go that's
great information that people uh were
insincere with you growing up or they
said one thing and meant another thing
or there were strings attached or they
over promised and under delivered or
they offered something and then made you
feel guilt when you actually took it
right or they made you believe that
their time was more valuable than yours
so let's start writing that up in your
fourth step you know it is what is the
um four-step story about how uh because
I think the key to all this is also
knowing whether you do one meeting or do
them all the time like like I do
you on some level believe that you're
terminally unique right if you're like I
don't want to tell anyone that bad thing
I did like oh you're the only person
right that stole a car you think you're
what you did was there's an arrogance to
what I did was so bad and then you get
someone read your fourth step which is
you admitting all the you know crazy
[ __ ] you've done and you're uh there's
like there's a story that's like yeah
and then I [ __ ] this chicken he's like
wasn't there a whole Coop you know the
[ __ ] one of them you know it just was
sort of like we've all done that and I
think it was um
uh Barry Michaels and who is the other
therapist that wrote the tools Phil
studs
um he uh talks about he said it so
elegantly Phil star he was he was the
big uh therapist psychologist in
Hollywood right yeah yeah being a
Hollywood
psychologist he was the guy that
everyone wanted to get with though right
yeah he's like very hard he's still
around
him and Phil Stutz who I'm sorry him and
Barry Michaels who is sort of his
Protege wrote that book called the tools
which I highly recommend some there's
some like antidotes that I think your
fan base would just find a little bit
you know too simple for them it's sort
of they already know it
um but there's some exercises that are
incredible that they put together the um
uh deathbed exercise where you picture
yourself on your Deathbed
like very vividly it actually really
helps put things in perspective right
the idea like being that if you're when
you're going through a problem or you're
having some kind of experience fast
forward to the death bed and then real
like then reflect on whatever you're
going through right now is this really
important I had a I mean you know I
struggle with eating disorders for a
very long time I had a really profound
experience when I was just was like oh
my God I would be so bummed if on my
deathbed I looked back and was like you
spent like years of your life like
counting calories
and like driving around the city buying
sugar-free protein bars like I just was
like my Futures I'm not gonna let that
happen to my future self like I will not
go down like that you know and it just
something clicked but when you're doing
the work and you're asking for you know
Illuminating of your psyche and your
inner monologue I think that when
something really simple hits you it
really can make a change in your brain
real fast yeah so control issues people
pleasing boundaries uh disordered eating
codependency like it's a whole bag of
tricks here so and you've done like so
much work right but like I'm interested
in like what's the because the on that
idea of like the road is always getting
narrower like you never transcend all of
this so what's the thing that's coming
up now what is the thing that you're
you're doing battle with and can I just
say really quick just in terms of
because I um what happens in vagueness
stays in Magnus and I think that um it
might be worth saying like you know in
these programs you say admitted to God
or power greater than yourself that you
are powerless over blank powerless over
alcohol powerless over cocaine Palace
over sex powerless over porn powerless
over whatever the thing is that you're
powerless over where it's no longer a
choice and and Al-Anon for me it changed
like in the beginning it started with um
I was powerless over other people's
behavior I would obsess over other
people's behavior I would try to why did
he do that why did he say that he
doesn't like me but hold on wait I
should have said that I shouldn't have
said that I mean just constant content
other and then I'm powerless over other
people's perceptions of me that I was
powerless over perfectionism that I was
powerless over uh worrying and panic
like worrying gave me a high I think
that that an addiction to anxiety and
panic is super real uh an addiction to
chaos you know I I'm powerless over
chaos I love chaos but it's all a choice
I'm the one getting in the car and
driving to his house yeah I'm the one
that drove over I'm the one that drove
at that Thanksgiving with my dad and his
new wife I'm the one doing that so did
you have a bunch of boyfriend friends
that were just chaos agents
that would fill that need
it's wild because I've been very lucky I
believe that in your 20s every if you're
in a bad whatever that means that's
normal you know what you do in your 20s
experimentation figuring things out you
know we need contrast you got to be in a
couple bad relationships so when the
right person comes along you're actually
going to be grateful and not be like
maybe there's more you know so there are
some that were just more childish than
anything
um but actually I was because I was so
precocious I was actually able to do
relationships pretty well with some
healthy people until I started
um being successful in terms of my you
know it took having the whole day free
to be able to maintain those
relationships which is a red flag
because I used to think that proximity
and intimacy went hand in hand so when I
was able to do it was dysfunctional at
the time if he went out of town I'd like
I'll come with you you know whatever so
afraid of being cheated on abandoned
left whatever
um and then I started I dated a couple
act
um a couple addicts were saying in
active addiction and there was one that
was so bad
um I was you know hiding crack pipes and
driving downtown and fighting with drug
dealers and that whole thing and I
really thought I was helping this person
you know I really
thought I could if someone just loved
him enough he would be sober that shows
my lack of understanding of basic
Neuroscience basic biology you know so
one of the first things they say to do
when you come into Al-Anon is study
addiction learn about it there's that
book
um uh addicts and addictive thinking I
think study alcoholism study what
happens to the brain because you're
going to take the behavior personally
and it has nothing to do with you you
know so that relapse had nothing to do
with you in fact you probably be like
where's the Croc bye where's is there
anything who just called you I mean like
no one that's not gonna help someone
right tolerate you know life without
being anesthetized if that's been their
choice so far and then you know I
believe you've mentioned this uh before
uh a rule that kind of helped me rule
whatever it is aphorism
is that you are the age you are minus
the amount of time you've been using
drugs so I was also in relationships
with people that had even if they were
sober they had been doing drugs since
they were 14 now they're 30 and just
emotionally they've haven't developed
their coping mechanisms yet they haven't
had an opportunity to have the Dignity
of their own experience like they're
still catching up emotionally and I was
expecting them to run with a broken leg
I was expecting them to be in a
relationship with the emotional
intelligence of a 14 year old yeah yeah
sorry yeah that's a big one I think
um people have this assumption that when
somebody gets sober and then maybe they
have a year or something like that like
oh they're fine like everything's fine
they're back
to you know being who they are but they
don't understand that you know they have
to learn how to be in the world like I
couldn't tell you how many years it took
for me to learn how to say no to like
anything like I had no ability to tell
me about that be an adult you know
meaning like would you feel like they'd
be mad at you sure
yeah but that showed up for me mostly As
avoidance like I just I'll respond to
that email later or I'll just like
pretend I didn't get that text where
they asked me that question and then you
get in those situations where time
passes and then the phone weighs a
million pounds which is so unfair to you
because I do that I used to do that all
the time I still you know I'm challenged
by that because to me if I send you a
text saying hey Rich you want to come to
my birthday and you're like just let me
just not
I like you so much like it'd be my
nightmare if I stressed you out with
that you know but I would never think
that it would be that much of a
challenge for you you know so it's sort
of like we are you know it's on us to
develop the coping mechanisms to be able
to go okay I've got this this is the
tool I used which is like I have on uh
in my voice
um notes in my notes app I put in I do a
lot of voice memoing um for my tent step
and stuff to like listen back and see if
I'm full of [ __ ] sometimes
um but is I have like three go-to
sayings for when someone asked me to do
something you know hey so good to hear
from you I am at capacity right now and
I just I can't commit to anything at the
moment can I let you know in a couple
weeks or hey can you actually send this
to with someone on that's my scheduler
so they can send to a fake email
whatever it is hey I just can't commit
right now here's if anyone is unhappy
with that response they're
uh not integrated and then the sooner we
start
um you know say what you mean mean what
you say don't say it mean instead of oh
hey oh you're invite you just invited me
it's next week if you don't put that
[ __ ] on them it's a great opportunity to
for both of you to practice maturity and
to see as you evolve in your program and
start re-parenting yourself to be mature
um in your expectations of other people
and not try to put your hooks in
everyone
you get to see who they are and then you
also you also get to get proof that
number one no one cares if you say no
right and no one cares when you cancel
you're doing them the biggest favor you
know the other response unhealthy
response is the multiple paragraph one
where you tell some long story about
like what you can't do so in my first
six months no emails longer than two
sentences
any email that is more than three
sentences you are either trying to
manipulate you're apologizing you're
trying to micromanage how they perceive
you you're trying to yeah guilt them or
shame them do they just you know same
thing oh and then I sent you that text
today I try to be very succinct but I
had to go nope he does not need to know
that that's me trying to make uh him
think I'm not an [ __ ] you know and
then I'm going oh this guy's that makes
me go oh this guy is has no ability to
judge me when he meets me or he's if he
thinks I'm an [ __ ] based on that one
extra sentence
there's probably something off with him
right you know but to really it takes
that recovery and that maturity to have
that thought occur to you maturity is
such a crazy word because I think
we associate it with being kids but as
an ACA adult child of alcoholic the
whole reason it's called that is because
we're still as adults behaving the way
we did when we were children and using
the tools that worked for us whether it
was like performing for everyone
shape-shifting for everyone you know
it's sort of if you had alcoholism in
your home or you had any kind of
neurodivergence or
um borderline personality which I think
just very recently we even have any
understanding of in the Zeitgeist and
it's all still pretty murkier
schizophrenia or compulsive behaviors
um you know you adapted that's the
wonderful thing about us is we can adapt
so quickly you know and then I know how
to keep everything we say at 70 degrees
so do you need anything do you need
anything just to make sure everyone
right the problem is that adaptation
gets calcified and when your environment
changes your adaptations don't change
with it unless you continue to go back
to those same strategies that you
learned as a young person just to
survive and get through the day and now
they're they show up as very unhealthy
healthy Behavior patterns that are
ruining your life and what programs do
is they take your brain off of auto
drive it takes it off your default
software so we go oh this is my default
software I'm going to update it and so
that I'm not operating on that same
software if that gets murky it'll always
default to that software it'll always
default to those thoughts that blueprint
you know if I'm hungry angry lonely
tired if I've skipped some meetings if
I've skipped you know you know doing any
of my rituals that keep me clear if I've
skipped hanging out with my friends that
think like this like I'm gonna start
getting further and further away from
that 2.0 and I'm going to start
defaulting you know if I'm scared if I'm
in a high stress situation so like I
gotta know that about myself but What
program does do for us is it gives us
pause I didn't know what that I had no
idea what that meant I was such a I know
we're not allowed to say spass but I was
such a manic person that was just always
in a rush always in a rush because I had
overbooked myself over committed to
stuff busyness was kind of an addiction
of mine not necessarily productivity but
just busyness it was a way of being
avoidant is the way having to be with my
feelings and keep that victim mentality
of like I'm always people want so much
for me and I just them you know that
martyr complex which by the way um so
one of the first questions I ask
sponsees and Al-Anon is I say okay if it
if you're going to the Rich Roll podcast
if it takes 30 minutes to get to Ritual
and you have to be there at three
o'clock what time do you leave
takes 30 minutes
what is the healthy response or what are
you doing what are the sponsee's
responses usually if they're just coming
into program like you leave at 3 30.
mm-hmm
because it takes 30 minutes to get there
right but then you show if anything
intervenes you're late magical thinking
yeah but if you run to someone you know
what if there's traffic whatever stops
your key what if you have you know
getting out of the car you want you
can't find the building like you're not
setting yourself up for a positive
result you're not giving yourself the
more typical they may say that but then
they'll still leave at 2 45 because
there's a self-sabotage aspect of it
like even if they're not consciously
aware that they're running late they'll
set themselves up so that they end up
leaving late and then that's a way to
flog yourself or to create stress on the
way there so you can tell yourself
you're a piece of [ __ ] or get the rush
of hormones that come with like I gotta
get you know like with making sure no
one respects you
you know so to me that is a form of
insanity in a form of exactly making
sure that you feel like [ __ ] later uh to
you know be an engine to your shame
addiction and you're bringing other
people into it which is especially you
know disrespectful but um you know I
think that that's something that you
know for me is a big one it's a very
small thing you know a lot of these big
problems I think have really basic
um Solutions so I have anxiety all day
okay try just for a week scheduling out
your day in a way that gives you an hour
between each thing if it takes 30
minutes but and then just see what
happens you know right see but the for
the unhealthy person it's like you know
yeah but whatever like I need the
complicated solution because I'm special
and my problems are special you don't
understand how terrible it is for me
yeah I know I look I I get it yeah so
you know what never mind then you know
what I'm so sorry never mind yeah you're
good I think and look with I went away
the first year of Allen on ACA I used it
I weaponized it I mean I because I went
in and I went I get exactly what this is
I'm too busy for this these I don't have
two new steps I got like I got the
intellectualization of it I did that too
and then I just had to relapse a ton of
times and end up in a treatment center
yep
that'll do it that's where intelligence
gets in the way sometimes a little bit
of program can be horrible for you
because you can use it you know to hover
up well I'm in this program so obviously
I'm right I mean well what they would
tell what this what they would say to do
is this and this obviously you know
you're like that's called being a
tourist in the program
because you're not actually doing it I'm
not going to go to the problem for the
solution and you're the problem so I'm
going to go get a salute like you can't
doing all that is you're just using it
to bully and shame other people and it
just makes your self-righteous
indignation addiction even worse did you
answer the question that I asked you
about what you're what's showing up for
you right now no because
because I owe you a couple answers how
is it showing up for me currently still
with the whack-a-mole of all of this you
know I do also think it's really
important to update your software on
yourself and on your recovery of going
like oh yeah I really needed this 10
years ago when I was in recovery but now
I don't know if I need that as much
anymore I think I need to be doing more
of this and also to go
you know recheck in because that
arrogant stuff will really the ego will
come right back up I remember during the
pandemic I did a couple Zoom meetings
and you know I'm like I've been doing
this for so long and I'm listening to
people who are just in the problem not
in the solution which to me comes off
like complaining but they're newcomers
you know so oh my work right now is to
be more patient with people the way they
were with me when I just came in and I
had no idea what I was doing and I
thought it was cool to just brag about
how bad my childhood was right or or to
approach the meeting from a perspective
of how you can help these people as
opposed to what am I extracting from
this that's helpful to me 100 or I'm
just here to look them in the eyes and
receive what they're saying God forbid
me not think about myself for three
minutes like take the win the respite
from having to think about yourself you
know but when I get that's what I love
about hearing other people share and
just being like okay it's not just me up
I'm not more special than anyone oh it's
not harder for me than it's forever run
I'm just a worker B I'm just a worker
bee but when judgment comes in that's
when I know I'm getting a little rusty
when gossip comes in especially at a
time where there's just so much gossip
um gossip is a really big sort of No-No
bottom line for a lot of al-anons
because it's sort of how we
um feel self-righteous that's how we
judge it's how we deal with fear it's
how we give ourselves a little
superficial hit of self-esteem just
because someone else made a mistake
that's not real self-esteem you know so
it's like the McDonald's version of
getting a little hit of self-esteem uh
Gossip is a big one and then the way I
handle gossip when it comes up you know
when someone's like oh my god did you
hear the Johnny Depp and they ever heard
thing and I'm like you know what I'm
just I would love to
um participate in this conversation I
just can't because but how does that
work as as a podcast host in the comedy
kind of ecosystem because that's sort of
part of it like you guys go on each
other's shows and you kind of talk about
each other and part of the comedy
derives from like whether it's you know
Johnny Depp and Amber Heard or
whatever's going on in the news right
well I my podcast is really
um kind of just focused on me writing
jokes about stuff and having you know
incredible people on but I tend to stay
you know
um try to go personal I don't want to
ever take cheap shots at anybody I don't
uh we end up cutting any of that out of
someone will like gossip about a
celebrity or something you have to bring
it back to yourself so Britney Spears uh
her conservatorship's over and she was
barefoot in a thing we're not gonna go
oh she's a trash hillbilly whatever and
go like I did that a lot as a kid should
we like should I be worried about
hookworm you know take it back to
yourself
um you know keep the focus on yourself
that's the sort of Al-Anon adage so for
me there's definitely been some things
that I'm like I need to sleep on it you
know
um if you were had trauma as a child a
rule that works for me is that anytime
you want to make a decision
um wait three days and then see if
that's still the decision you want to
make because it's a good rule feelings
aren't facts uh and I might be having a
histrionic reaction I might be in fight
or flight mode I might not have halted
today I might just be like wanting to
get those likes because I know this will
go viral and I'm exploiting someone else
that you know so I'm a big don't just do
something sit there person almost two
I've almost gone the other way you know
when I first got into program my big
thing um I was saying yes to everything
and being exhausted I was sick all the
time I had Costa chondritis like my
chest started ripping apart I had
pleurisy in my back like I was just not
sleeping going from party to uh of a
person I didn't really like that much to
hike with another person I didn't really
even like that much you know running
around doing quote favors to People by
pretending to like them psycho and um
so
for me it was you know the answer to
most things is just no yeah it starts as
no
I like how on your podcast you have I
mean you have a lot of Comedians and
entertainers but then every once in a
while it's like oh it's David Sinclair
like you know there's like a little
overlap with what I do here I know and I
always get such a kick out of that and
then and then sometimes they're like
deer and headlights they're like what is
going on here like what what is
happening
I
[Laughter]
one time Robert Greene was on the
podcast and I was like uh I literally
opened with I love all your books I've
read all your books you know who else
loves your books is Donald Trump like he
loves and he's like are you saying I'm
why
he and I was like oh no no I just didn't
right sorry okay let me like recalibrate
to a professional adult that I'm talking
to you know so I always try to ask
questions that no one else would ask um
you know and it's it's cool because I
get to watch your podcast and hit two
birds with one stone because I think the
way people consume these now is someone
will look up
You Know Rich Roll who and then that's
well if I had you on my podcast and then
it would be the whole side of the thing
would be other interviewers with you so
someone's in a wormhole on you and then
they watch my pocket then they watched
Tim Ferriss and I've asked all the same
questions and then sure huberman asked
all the same question so I like to
really watch everything and go hear the
questions nobody has asked this person
so that when they're in a wormhole we're
not just all boring ourselves to tears
and so usually the questions end up
being a little wild right that's good I
like it we have to talk about DC do you
know I'm from DC no yes what because
what I was going to say earlier is that
I also had this weird tinge of luck
which I don't think we do this enough
I'm a big gratitudeless person I don't
like it but I do it just because it
works not because I enjoy it and one I
think a lot of times we don't look at
our childhood and go what was like
advantageous like let me okay I can all
day complain about the things that
weren't but in DC when I was
10 11 12 13 the coolest people to hang
out with and my boyfriend my first
boyfriend was straight edge
and that was the cool thing Discord uh 9
30 Club 9 30 Club XXX everywhere like
that was my thing fugazi like it was all
about like being sober is cool and I
just happened to get that information
I'm sure that I gravitated towards it
because it was complete opposite of what
I would see at home but I I think I got
a good a little bit lucky and going like
the coolest people are the ones that
don't do drugs yeah it's so funny
because I have so many cool straight
edge friends now like guys that came up
in punk rock and were part of that world
and still playing bands and stuff like
that
but I grew up not I did I was not like
going to the 9 30 club and I was asked
because it's your Wikipedia says you're
born in Malibu I grew up in DC my
parents lived in Georgetown now they
still live in Georgetown where I grew up
uh I went to The Landings for boys what
high school did you go go to you went to
London I did this is a trip I went to St
Andrews my mom was a teacher at Walt
Whitman
[ __ ] out really yeah so I mean that was
the public high school that I would have
gone to if I didn't I I grew up in
Bethesda for elementary school I went to
Kyle no no no no I went to a private
elementary school no no it was off
MacArthur like in DC
[Music]
no I want to say St Stevens but that's
St Patrick's that's where I went you
went to St Patrick's we went to the same
Elementary School
[Laughter]
is it all I mean I'm older I'm way older
than you but like that's crazy
and then I went to and then I went I
went from there to Landon
you did the entire you went all the way
so I went no I went seventh seventh to
12th at Landon
and my mom
worked at uh
your mom worked at Whitman well my mom
did public relations for uh Marcus
Stephen Marcus Gallery Bloomingdale's
and White Flint and Tysons my brothers
that was my jam my brother was a bouncer
at Third Edition
no way you for sure met yeah I
definitely I was there and I would go
there and I would go to Garrett's sure I
was a tombs [ __ ] uh the guards assumes
uh the Georgetown Pub too Georgetown
Club what was Georgetown Pub like it on
the campus Tavern oh I don't remember
you went to Georgetown no I didn't no no
wait you said okay my parents yeah like
I came to California for college
but grew up in DC and then would go back
and spent my summers in DC during
college it's just such a trip all right
we'll talk more about that later but I'm
really into where you were born has a
very big impact on the way you think
yeah and I one of the reasons I I
brought it up not just because it's
somewhat shared history like your dad
was a lawyer right my dad was a lawyer
he was in he was a government lawyer and
then when I was in high school he went
to a firm and your dad was like at Aaron
Fox right
are you like the new nardwar that was on
that was on Wikipedia that was on
Wikipedia oh I don't think that's true I
think my dad on Wikipedia is also named
the name that we named my dad in my
television show so a lot of people like
Western documentary there was a live
studio audience you know so my dad um uh
went to Cambridge for law he was
so brilliant and so funny and um looked
exactly like Dan Aykroyd everyone
thought he was Dan Aykroyd when I was a
kid he would sign autographs as Dan
Aykroyd and I'd be like you know and
then I'd see that like I fully thought
he was Dan Aykroyd one of the reasons I
brought up DC is you know DC is a very
unique place there's a little bit of
shared DNA with LA because they're
company towns you live in DC it's all
about politics when you grow up as a kid
and you're going to high school there
you're very well versed and everything
that's going on mostly because it's like
what is it why can't we get to
Maggiano's like Janet Reno's barricade
like you learned that way oh constantly
that kind of stuff
um but it's also a town where
um
it's not really like like Prestige
doesn't derive from Material wealth it's
about proximity to power and it's all
and it's also very much about
um academic Excellence like it's all
like everybody's driving their Volvo
with the stickers on the back where
their kids go to school and as a child
like this was the game that I was
playing and and what was reinforced in
my house to be very achievement oriented
and I got very good at that game like
that was my coping strategy for
procuring love and acceptance and and
and the like and it's a longer story
um but you know
it's my version of what you shared where
the world smiles on you for all of these
things until you kind of you know crash
that car into a wall and realize like
you need new strategies for long-term
well-being it's so interesting when you
just said that and this is how hard I've
worked even if you don't like me or
think I'm funny or saw that I was on the
podcast I'm like oh you know like this
changed my life like clearly and the you
know I look at recovery as like you know
like train tracks like there's this
group these grooves like you said that
have been calcified or Christopher
crystallized in our brain of this is how
I treat this person this is what I do in
this situation and it's about just like
like weakening those and opening new
group just new making new neural
Pathways you know and so as soon as you
just said my dad
valued academic Excellence because I had
a very similar thing that I think is
worth talking about I just thought oh my
God that is so cool that his dad
just really wanted to set him up to win
in life his dad had obviously been
through something that was like you need
to be able to do this and this and you
need to get A's because I can't help you
after this like the only thing I do have
control of is instilling a wild work
ethic in you and that's what happened to
me my dad used to always tell me this
might not be like
the going science on what's healthy for
kids fine but it really worked for me my
dad always told me life is not fair and
you're always going to have to work
twice as hard to get half as much and
then even when you deserve something
you're not going to get it a lot so I
would come home with a B plus but I
studied all night and did it and there's
the bell curve and the thing and I
should be able to get a name he goes
life's not fair you don't deserve an a
you got to be plus you know and that was
really helpful to me I mean this is
going to sound well but my dad used to
wake me up at two in the morning who
cares why that was the time he was
available that's another story but we'll
wake me up at two in the morning and
like drill me with vocabulary words wow
and the test for the next day and the
whole thing you know and spell it
backwards spell it forwards and the
kicker of it is that you know figuring
out the way that your primary character
is sorry
figure out the way your primary
caretaker's thought is super helpful you
know I think it's super healing as well
you know so my dad he always wanted to
make sure that I was prepared for
anything because the whole thing is like
you can be prepared for this but you're
not prepared for all the things that are
going to go wrong so SAT prep we
couldn't afford that you know people say
that the whole Rick Singer thing with
college admissions it's unfair even
without someone taking tests for a rich
kid it's already unfair because at
sophomore year the rich kids start using
sat tutors they say you know they
already have an advantage and he was
very clear about like yeah you're gonna
do all this but then a boy you have a
crush on is going to come in holding
hands with another girl what's gonna
happen you're gonna forget to eat and
this and that you know so he wanted me
to be so good that I could do it like
with my eyes closed distracted hungry
all of them
yeah a bit of a tiger dad
served you well though it makes me it
makes me really emotional to think about
it because um I regret all the time that
I
my ego needed to blame my parents for
the bad choices I made or the bad
instincts I had or the broken you know
DNA or intuition because I look back and
even even if what your parents are doing
is malicious there's just no way you
cannot turn it into a superpower there's
just there's no way unless they cut off
your leg but you know my mom worked
three jobs and then she came home and
then she worked you know that was a mom
clean the house would rearrange the
house you know maybe slightly
pathologically you know because she
didn't have control in other areas but I
always felt neglected I spent most of my
uh high school and years as a child in
the White Flint Bloomingdale's just
walking around yeah you know and just
walking around shoplifting but I but
what I didn't realize I was doing at the
time my narrative was I'm a neglected
child I was talking to adults I was
talking to the Cosmetics girl and then I
was like can I do the perfume and then I
would go up to a stranger and be like
excuse me would you like to smell this
perfume you know like I learned how to
talk to adults I learned how to speak
publicly you know and it was kind of a
weird wild brilliant gift that I got
that I take no credit for you know
people like you work so hard I'm like I
only work 12 hours a day what do you
mean I still and then I lived in Roanoke
Virginia and we lived on a farm and as
soon as you know you got home from work
at seven o'clock then the work started
then you start cleaning out the Stalls
and you start getting the hay and you
know so I got really really lucky that I
just inherited this work ethic and it's
just normal to me
yeah but it's so beautiful how you
reflect back on on your parents in that
way like that's actually really helpful
to me yeah I just think also you know in
program we go oh take a contract action
if you want to text your ex just don't
if you think it's a good idea just don't
do it call me first you know sometimes
that's just the the deal in the
beginning but
to me I try to take contrary thoughts
and I also don't take my thoughts that
seriously I look at my inner monologue
as like a science fiction movie It's
like Star Wars or something you know
it's just like Rich doesn't like me that
was weird
that was weird whether you do or not it
doesn't matter you know and it's like I
just made that up in my head like what
was that no one needed that and then uh
Argus Hamilton uh been uh a comedian
that's been around forever sure Legend
he um no Argus
he said once to me he was like um
give your Character defects names and
make them people that are trying to help
you
um and they're just trying to help you
at the wrong time that's cool that
helped me have so much compassion you
know so girl will walk by gorgeous
whatever young Charming dating a guy
used to have a crush on I'm like oh whoa
Jenny what was that why are you trying
to I know this sounds I'm really
encouraging trying to make you feel
better it doesn't this isn't how it
looks by the way I'm not this crazy but
I'll be like okay that wasn't me that
was my inner child that was old
programming why did that happen because
she's probably lovely and I'm not meant
to be with him so why did my body want
to do that oh number one a thousand
years ago my body would just like be
procreate at all costs you know that's
some old [ __ ] that you know is
unnecessary I have an IUD why are you
trying to procreate it's not that's not
what we're doing here like fast forward
to the present and then um go like what
was that oh yeah okay I know what that
was that was just me if I I villainize
her then I she's less pretty and less of
a threat to me like what am I doing
right and then I can kind of just break
it apart and go oh you know what that
was really helpful a long time ago when
family members had secret families and
were picking women over me that helped
me take an action to then involve myself
and charm them and try to get their
attention back because I equated it as
safety or whatever
um and then I just like kind of break it
down and go like nope not mine not mine
not mine it's like the way you would go
or thank you Jenny but maybe later not
now not her this isn't the time when the
homeless meth addict breaks into my
house which will be any day now that's
what I need I need Bill to get off the
bat maybe he's coming to return your
computer and they're also
and they're also pit I look at them as I
look at thoughts as my inner child's
pitches
you know what I mean that person might
be trying to steal from you be careful
no he's not lie why why still what yeah
that's not going to make the Slate you
know what I mean it's just one might go
to Pilot but maybe no further no exactly
but like you know what sit on the bench
I love you you are only trying to
protect me and you're only trying to
keep me alive so half of it is nature
who's our brains only priority is to
Keep Us Alive yeah not I hate this right
I'm not wrong I mean it's like how can
you get your brain from surviving to
thriving and anytime I make a decision I
try to go is this just me trying to
survive or is this me actually thriving
because why am I in survival mode um
yeah just that question alone why am I
in survival mode
even if you try to steal me on that that
argument whatever comes up it's going to
break down because there generally isn't
a reason for you to be in survival mode
or some kind of flight or fight response
to a relatively benign interaction and
why do you hate your future self so much
that you're not willing to think this
way mindlessly and consciously
why are you not trying to make a
positive contribution to your future
self
because I don't deserve it Whitney okay
how's that going
you know I don't know I've been doing it
my whole life
it's worked pretty well for you that's
the other thing a lot of these things
work well for people you know and so
they don't right I think the thing is
it's scary to change and if you have if
that Groove is dug so deep and you're
telling somebody like Hey listen like
this thing you've been doing your whole
life like you should probably discard it
or think of a new way like
how do you even begin to do that and if
it's something that's not tangible
you've been gambling your whole life
throw the cards away you've been doing
drugs your whole life get don't go to a
bar and get rid of the drug you know but
it's like things like eating addictions
and sex addictions and behavior
addictions like this these are things we
move through the world all we have to do
at least three times a day you know
sorry sex I don't have sex every time
today I'm not gonna have that kind of
time right which is you know it's
it's something you have to have a lot
more compassion for than the drug addict
or whatever or because because you have
to eat three times a day like you're
confronted inevitably with this you know
David Sinclair would not say you have to
eat three times a day though so maybe
definitely would not there's a lot of
people right now a lot of people have
been on this podcast who would say you
shouldn't have to worry about three
times a day well let's just say once a
day minimum see what works for you how
about that I am someone that has
migraines that did not work for me so
right but I also you know I know I'm
kind of joking but it's sort of like the
this is gonna get me in too much trouble
so I'm not going to set up that way but
I will say that um you know intermittent
fasting like don't eat all I'm like we
invented that women I was anorexic for
20 years there's a lot of people and and
probably a lot of men who are using
intermittent fasting and fasting to to
hide their dysfunctional eating sure
yeah which is you know it is fascinating
that you have brought all this um to
life just in general I also wanted to
just bring up a couple things just that
you just inspired me about like just
little tools you know that I think we
all sleep on that are so basic and
everyone has access to
um which are is music and animals that
was my next thing I wanted to get into
the animals so go I just want to say
something that really helps me is that
I'm very weird about
I need to over pathologize that but I am
very intentional about the way I use
music to help my life and help my
equilibrium in my brain so when I drive
around I don't listen to music
um I'll listen to podcasts sometimes but
other times I'm like I need this time to
just hang out with myself like I need we
don't do a lot of processing I was at
you know cheer the um uh about navera
cheerleaders it's a show on Netflix oh
yeah about the best cheerleaders you
know in the world and um I was talking
to one of them and athletes there's so
much to learn from great athletes
because just the concept of discipline
and the concept of knowing what you need
and not being able to fake it you know
if you have an injury you can't be like
I'm fine like you can't be dishonest
with yourself or other people because
you could get permanently hurt or you
could hurt someone else especially in
cheerleading because if you're at the
bottom of a pyramid and you're like oh
no I'm fine if you're people-pleasing or
being codependent a lot of people could
get hurt so there's just no concept of
not telling the truth about your
limitations right I think you know
non-athletes really are not fun I'm good
like I can I can lift that like there's
a you know a respect for uh reality and
a living and a sort of radical
realism and so I was talking to um
Morgan who's sort of a big star of the
show she's she's just the
she's just the mo the grittiest
um most incredible it's a very
triumphant story of what she came from
and you know how she'd overcome some
obstacles and you know it's about in you
know it's not even about inches uh when
it comes to cheerleading I mean it's
about you know iota's like the tiniest
centimeter you miss and it's over so
it's about radical perfectionism so
you're like oh these people must be nuts
you know uh and unrecovered I remember I
went and saw it in uh when I was in
Austin and uh the live show and I said
to Morgan because for the last two years
she's just gotten famous off this
television show uh and I was like what
are you gonna do like for the summer and
she's like oh I'm taking the entire
summer off just to process
um and I was like how old is she 19
right that's definitely like a new thing
but like it wasn't like to like sit with
my crystals it wasn't like that it was
like to Pro I was like what does it mean
process she's like the last two years
it's been a whirlwind I'm just gonna
like write my journal and just process
I was like what since
I didn't even know that was an option
right I go through life just like well
that's over with that's over with that's
over and we don't take time to just go
or like this is the moment to double
down and capitalize like it's not going
to be like this forever I have an
opportunity better make this work like
Now's the Time to hustle overdrive and
then I'll process later but you got to
schedule that processing time you know
and we get it a little bit with our 10th
Step at night when you know the 10 step
is anyone can do even if you're not in
program of just sit down you know before
you go to bed and get a pen out and just
go like how did I do today like am I
okay that that wasn't great I probably
shouldn't have said that oh I
interrupted her in the meeting I should
probably tomorrow just apologize right
now hey you might not even have noticed
this but I interrupted you earlier and
I'm sorry that was rude you know
whatever and then it is the best feeling
in the world to apologize to people
that's what I'm addicted I'm addicted to
apologizing but not in the way that
every woman just moves through the world
apologizing constantly it's not I'm the
opposite on that because I
your behavior owning your behavior you
know it is just a way to
this is too gross of a matter of fact
it's just like taking the best piss of
your life you know because you're just
like removing all that guilt all that
shame we say you can't stay clean on the
shower you took yesterday so it's
basically a way of just clearing the
Slate of any resentments guilts like oh
you know what I don't like the way I
responded to that that was you know what
next time I'm gonna do it better great
living amends to myself you know just
process locking in the growth I also
call it because we hear so much
brilliant stuff right now you know I'm
gonna listen to Virtual and then I'm
gonna listen to patrol and then I'm like
go for a walk
and like process what he just said lock
in that growth you know so many people
were like I heard this podcast it
changed my life I'm like what'd it say
um something about like you know what I
mean and you're like we're the same way
when we read books now we're like just I
can read five pages and go I could not
tell you what I just read right if I'm
not going to be sort of mindful well
there's also the weird
dopamine-inducing experience of reading
that thing or maybe you know the the
inspirational quote that you see on
Instagram and then and then feeling
accomplished when you actually haven't
channeled any of that into any behavior
modification nothing it's nothing yeah
and um the music thing is just something
that I just kind of realized about
myself
um because I said it out loud to people
and they were like what where I'm so
emotionally reactive to music you might
not be or your listeners you know may or
may not be but know what activates you
like know what is a natural form of
Adderall or whatever people take today
like energy coffee whatever where I
won't listen to musical I won't waste
music you know what I mean I won't waste
it like meaning it's not it's not a
background soundtrack it's intentional
to you know induce a state of being or
awareness totally elevate your
experience and I don't just like turn on
the radio because I don't know what I'm
gonna get hit with if I hear Billy
eilish I'll be the whole my whole day
shot you know because I'm like in my
emotions and now I guess so powerful
Billy Island I know we'll just you know
she's I'll you know something emotional
sorry Sinead O'Connor's Nothing Compares
or something you know you never know
what emotional landmine you're gonna
like fall into that's gonna derail you
uh and conversely you can really get a
lot of energy from music I mean of
course power songs you know your gym mix
whatever but I will be very mindful
about what song I'm playing when and
what I need to hear and I'll go like
okay I'm feeling kind of tired I'm gonna
go to the gym I'm gonna have some coffee
but you know what I'm not gonna to do
that I'm just gonna
put on Beyonce CEO whoever your person
is you know mxpx or you know
I can do this all day long uh but now
I'm now like oh he's gonna think I'm
corny if I mention DC Henry Rollins I
don't know and it it will have knowing
the impact it has on me I will use it to
my advantage and a lot of people are
like how'd you do that I'm like I just
play how'd you write that book how'd you
write that script I just blasted Rage
Against the Machine for two hours you
know so that's something I think we kind
of sleep on sometimes right let's talk
about the animals
okay
I want to know uh how this deep
relationship that you have with animals
began and I want to talk about
the the kind of healing modalities that
you've explored with this I mean
particularly Equine Therapy I know
you've talked about it a lot but I think
it's really powerful
thank you I'm gonna
um I feel overwhelmed I'm just gonna say
that out loud and I'm gonna I'm just got
a little bit afraid of being boring
that's like one of my biggest fears and
I just caught it and I'm just gonna slow
down
um so being boring what's that anything
I'm I'm like it's getting warm in here
it's getting hot freaking hot out we
have to turn the air conditioner off for
this thing so mostly I am in a swamp on
your very expensive chair um so growing
up again this is a thing I got lucky for
I thought it was you know horrible abuse
at the time because no one was around to
raise me and I spent most of my summers
in Roanoke Virginia and a couple years
of my teenage years
um and I lived with my aunts
um things were just too chaotic at home
you know I know this is something you
don't hear a lot in like L.A New York
but in other you know there's more to
America than just that in the midwest
sometimes in the South it's not that
unusual to go live with your aunts or
your grandfather you know whatever if
things are getting a little bit hectic
uh which they were to say the least so
um but I always was with my whole every
summer my whole childhood I didn't go to
camps I didn't go to
um I mean I did do the YMCA Camp one
that left a mark that was I need to talk
to my embr therapist about that camp but
you'd go you'd go to the country in the
summertime and I just spent time with
animals and it was the safest I felt so
you know I had had you know sexual abuse
as a child and adults were just kind of
scary to me if they were around at all
so between those two things you know
kind of auspicious kind of not but I
um my aunt my Aunt Lisa and Kathy live
right next to each other uh both people
who are uh just animal people I come
from Appalachia so you have two ants and
they both lived in separate houses on
the same like Farm exactly same road
that just sort of forked and one
personality was sort of incredibly
um you know Southern Charm perfect China
all the time house is perfect uh Mary
Chapin Carpenter what's that song
um uh he thinks he'll keep her
um just about everything was right in
place the perfect napkins and the
perfect and the homemade everything and
everything from scratch and then my
other aunt was just like the most punk
rock animal [ __ ] you can imagine she
had 15 cats something like 18 dogs and
everyone in the neighborhood or
surrounding area if their dog had a
medical problem they couldn't afford to
fix you would just wake up and there
would be like a basset hound tied to the
tree so we've been taking new animals
all the time people would just leave
puppies in bags stuff like that and then
there were tons of horses and I just
they were
the only people I could understand I
couldn't understand adults there was
just so I mean look if getting into
whatever neurodivergence I have you guys
feel free to diagnose me I'm sure it's
just as valid as whatever doctor told me
this 20 years ago
um but horses I could understand dogs I
could understand cats I could understand
the adults I couldn't understand because
they would act one way and then we would
go to church on Sunday and it said don't
lie don't cheat and then they would lie
or do and I'm like I don't understand
this or they would be like all right I
love you love you totally indirect
communication totally sloppy
communication I'm fine no I'm fine as a
kid you're like I know you're not
but why would you lie so I must just be
dumb or a piece of [ __ ] or I just have
to doubt everyone all the time it just
it erodes your ability to trust and I
just was like I must just not I felt
very lonely around people I felt very
stressed out around them I couldn't
understand them I didn't understand
their value system it was obviously an
alcoholic home so people were very
distracted with lots of things and
horses I understood horses are very
direct communicators because they're
prey animals they don't lie they don't
um try to charm you or beguile you and
they're very fair they're very fair and
and I do very well when something is
clear and fair there's nothing you can
say it's not about what you're saying
it's about how you're saying it you know
so it's like I love you I'm like that's
scary I'm scared of that I'm scared of a
dissonance between what someone's saying
and how they're saying it and that's a
lot of the codependent you know a lot of
us you know we've inherited it you know
epigenetically uh and you know religion
probably didn't help but you never say
what you're actually thinking and but
can you pass the can you pass the
can you pass the pepper or not or you're
not oh okay well
right can you do anything because you
couldn't pass the ball in high school oh
you couldn't do that and then there's an
explosion yeah there's a huge fight over
semen but everything is loaded it always
yeah with so much and between each other
too it's like oh look who decided to
show up
[Music]
something as little a hey stranger I'm
like that's not a stranger that's our
uncle we just saw you know so all that
sort of like resent many indirect
communication and then I'm around
animals and I'm like I get it if a horse
kicks at you you were too close got it
and being a prey animal the horses are
very Adept at at reading Behavior right
so they understand like and so there you
can't have dissonance between what
you're saying and how you actually feel
right they root that out so it it's like
a
um a great like vehicle or almost a
mirror exercise for integrating your
emotions with your words that's what
you're being authentic yeah yeah and
because sometimes you do have to tell
this to people like animals don't know
what you do for a living they don't know
you're famous they don't they don't care
all they do is value Serenity and
Tranquility they also don't need you to
guy they can't like
um uh you can't control an animal that
is a horse or a prey animal with treats
like they have grass they already have
food they need nothing from you so the
only motivation a truly wild and not
broken spirited horse the only benefit
of being around you would be Tranquility
or that you have leadership qualities
and that you become the lead mayor and
so what's so incredible about horses
other prey animals but let's just talk
about horses is they want you to be
Regal they want you to be powerful they
want you to be in charge whereas most
people want you to be small
right they want you to be humble they
don't want you to talk too much about
your accomplishments because then that
makes me feel bad I don't want you to be
in charge I don't want you to be the
alpha I'm the [ __ ] Alpha Man horses
are just like they want you to be in
charge because we're a herd right so
you're only as strong as your weakest
link so it's like oh if a horse doesn't
respect you it usually means you don't
respect yourself how are you carrying
yourself do you find yourself
apologizing to the horse are you being
results oriented are you trying to take
a selfie the horse doesn't know what
that is all it feels is your desperation
all it feels is fear of this isn't going
well fear of not getting a photo fear of
not looking good fear of and it's just
like fear and then it has to look around
and go are there any Bobcats around or
cougars that we need to worry about so
they want to get away from you right or
does the horse like me the horse doesn't
like me
the fact that you're asking that
question is the reason it doesn't like
you so it's basically like it's just
horses are repelled by insecurity
micromate all the things that I'm trying
to minimize uh in myself characteristic
wise they're repelled by so you really
have to learn if you want to spend time
with a horse in a way that's not abusive
and that you're not gonna embarrass it
or degrade it or um exploit it you have
to be the kind of person that that horse
would want to hang out with right so in
an Equine Therapy context like explain
that modality and how that works to you
know help somebody who who does come in
with all of these you know sort of
issues how does the how does working
with the horse help heal that person I
think that before you even spend any
time with a horse it's already so
educational when I say you're a horse
person probably I haven't spent a lot of
time with horses interesting yeah so a
lot of people like but I'm super
interested about this and the more I
learn about it like I I want to know
more they are an actual mirror but we
are are of course now talking about
horses I'm not talking horses that
carriage horses that are abused or
horses that have been broken so a lot of
horses that have been trained to let
anyone get on them their spirit is
broken they're not a horse that you want
to do Equine Therapy with because
they're gone like they have surrendered
to the fact that they are just just
prostitutes they have nothing left they
have no connection with you so the first
thing is establishing a connection with
a horse where you know you're going to
want it to run up to you and you know
the first thing we do when we see a
horse what do we do
you want to pet his nose and see if
he'll you know because someone walked up
to you
and just started touching your face that
you had never met
right how disrespectful that is
it's just the most basic it's the most
basic thing and I think that for us as
as humans we have just forgotten common
sense like can you imagine if I just
jumped on your back
and asked you to give me a piggyback on
a hike I mean it's just yes horses were
bred to do this of course horses like I
hear I know everything that everyone's
thinking as I say this but if you want
to get the medicinal benefits from this
animal you have to think this way you
know and it helps train your brain to go
that person was kind of a dick why was
that guy such a dick and then you go
wait why did I
give him a hug before wait his wife was
I sort of still had his wife or whatever
it is whatever forensics you need to do
you get to take responsibility for
what's going on around you and the way
people react to you and you get to get a
very fair
um assessment of your energy and what
you give off you know are you giving off
true Alpha of [ __ ] or are you frazzled
and scared if a horse if you need a
horse's approval that horse is like I
can't you're not safe
around like you are a problem for this
herd you know or something's wrong with
you they don't understand that when
someone's uh Behavior Uh and thoughts
are in Congress because Horses Don't Lie
they don't do [ __ ] like that you know
and also horses they resolve conflicts
and it's over they don't hold on to it
they just kick each other in the face
and then it's over instead of just like
and then I can't believe that happened
they don't hold on to that because it's
not auspicious for them because it can
it takes up too much energy and they
need to be energy conservation experts
because you never know when you get that
next patch of grass you know so vultures
fascinate me too because of the way that
they have to save energy and that's
something we don't think about as humans
it's like why are you just wasting your
energy on all this stuff you know I
they've taught me about energy
conservation you know I now think about
my life as every day I have 100 energy
dollars and by five o'clock if I've
spent 60 you know sixty dollars of my
energy dollars and then someone's like
do you want to go to dinner and I'm like
well I still have to work out and I
still have to read that script and I
still have to write some jokes so I'll
be at 90 energy dollars and this person
takes like 40 energy dollars I can't
because then I'll be borrowing from the
next day and then I'll be on a deficit
so that helps me and that's how horses
operate also so growing up when I was
around horses I always felt safe because
I all they're they're
Behavior was always Fair
you know their behavior was always fair
and they only think to take care of
themselves for the most part and when
you watch horse Behavior a lot when they
do interact and quote help each other
it's always an equal exchange and it's
always to be of service so they'll groom
each other you know side by side even if
they've just got in a fight 10 minutes
ago it's all of service and um
and so I was just the only time I felt
sane was around horses the only time I
truly understood what was going on was
around horses and I was obsessed with
them I was also obsessed with the
discipline around it and putting the
saddle away and cleaning the saddle and
you know I just loved the ritual of it I
loved the responsibility required I
loved how sensitive horses are because
I'm really sensitive so you know I have
misophonia which is when you just hear
things just really loud and horses have
super hero hearing so he you know my
horse hears bamboo from a mile away and
I'm like you heard that I okay all right
I'm not crazy okay good this is probably
an advantage like a genetic advantage
and then it makes you think about like
oh what was my purpose or my ancestors
purpose in tribal times because I also
have trouble sleeping and then I learn
about the night watcher Theory which is
you know a lot of people that are
insomniacs their ancestors ancestors
ancestors were the people in the tribes
before street lights and security guards
that stayed up all night to look for
threats and assess threats they were the
night Watchers and the night Watchers
bred with the night Watchers and they
you know uh basically have a circadian
rhythm that's just off they just
inherited it you know it's a superpower
but not you know if you're trying to
sleep
ten to six and um but it gets very um
empowering I hate that word
um too many idiots use it sorry because
horses take responsibility for
themselves and you study their breed to
know more about them dogs as well you
know I only rescue dogs obviously but
when you go what the first thing I can
do to understand this dog is understand
what it was bred to do and understand
where it gets its dopamine and what it
needs like you know so I was on the um
sorry path was a path um what is it
Forward path mindset what is that path
forward I don't even know what that is
it was the The ancestral um the guy you
just had on Whose dad was not oh long
pass long time sorry okay I'm so
disgusting long path I said path I don't
know what I said forward path forward
okay well I'm starting that that's a
path I'm starting that okay okay Andrew
Yang might already be doing that but
like
yeah
um and uh so then you start going like
oh well this is a uh Australian Shepherd
they're bred to herd they cannot see the
world in any other way when humans are
standing too far apart an Australian
Shepherd needs to hurt you they need you
two to get together or else you're gonna
bark they're gonna freak out they're
gonna tear up your [ __ ] and we go what's
wrong with this dog why is it tearing up
it's not a dog it's an Australian what
it's supposed to doing what it is wired
to do I know so many people in La
they're like I want to get a husky they
have such pretty blue eyes I'm like okay
do you run 20 you're the only person the
chef husky 20 miles a day we have uh we
have great Pyrenees oh wow which are
beautiful Regal wow wow wow and then
they need a lot of you know like they
need a lot of exercise and I think it's
too hot for them here I don't think it's
great for them environmental wise but
I mean it's also I that's a different
conversation for another day because
also I think that all these animals are
adaptable and resilient and there's
always some kind of solution so you know
people's biggest thing is I can't adopt
a big dog or I can't adopt a dog I don't
have a yard I'm like I don't have a big
house and dogs are dead animals they
look small they like small places the
more territory that they believe they
have to protect the more stressed out
they get so actually you get a calmer
dog when you have a smaller space or you
know keep midmar so that's not that
doesn't apply to that but just in
general and um so it made me start
asking like oh I was so reverent of the
ancestry what they were bred to do
yet completely oblivious that that would
apply to humans like in humans or
animals like just the idea of like oh
then why do I do this oh my god well my
ancestories Appalachia
superhero hearing and why am I so
uncomfortable in small spaces and
elevators oh right my grandfather was
in Coal Mines right why would we be any
different
why are we not all in nursing homes
asking our grandmothers our great aunts
like what was our my grandfather like
what's my great great felon and then
something very spooky happened that I'll
just
tell you and we'll get back to the
medicinal qualities forces
um
I did something called family
constellation which is what
dude my wife's all about this go ahead
am I your nightmare no it's great so I'm
I will say it loud I'm proud I believe
it's a pseudoscience uh I don't believe
it's a science maybe I'm missing
something but I also believe that all
humans we know so much more than we
think we know like all knowledge has to
be verbal it all has to be written we
forget about our intuition we forget how
much information we already have and I
think that I remember one time um
there's the psychic that I went to way
way back in the day and um everything
she said was right
and I was like oh my God she's psychic
uh and then I was like wait a second
ask me um about my uh relationships well
I I you're the psychic uh so I can't
decide what to do but between these two
guys I'm dating
um I can't decide which one like like
there's this one guy uh his name is Jim
and um
you know like he's really like I really
like him
you know but like
I don't know and then there's this guy
Kevin who was like he's so normal like
he's so supportive like he
I don't know I just can't decide
you're not gonna end up with either of
them well that's true
[Music]
and then I'm like psychic we have no
idea how much information we are giving
with the way we say things in our
non-verbal sure and the more the more
one knows about how you're wired it's
easier to predict you know you that
person can see what you can't see which
is that you'll default to your behavior
patterns better or worse and end up with
the person that you kind of historically
have always ended up with despite your
best intentions to be with somebody else
for sure but what she said was like Jim
Jim is not the right match right now oh
my God you're right but the I already
knew that right I I needed someone to
say what I already knew
gem is I mean he's like he's really not
like when we're but you're probably more
likely to end up with Jim
that's the thing yes for sure but the
way I was saying it the way that I was
apologizing for him I was defending him
Etc you know so to me we're telegraphing
you're already defending this person
you're already but like look he doesn't
have like he doesn't do great at like
movie theaters you know but like when
we're alone it's like you're you already
everyone already knows we're all so
psychic we just kind of are like
um and so that is something that you
know to think about as I say so family
constellation someone basically comes
and here's the other thing that it does
that is a miracle even if nothing else
happens about this they encourage you to
just quite simply ask your living
ancestors questions
we are sitting on the biggest wealth of
information and insight on the planet
and it's old people we think they're
stupid we put them in homes we lock them
away and they're dumb and they don't use
Facebook and they don't know how to text
and they don't know how to use giffies
whereas like half of the issues that you
know my mom's in a nursing home I'll
just go down the hall to some woman
named Rita who no one will talk to
anyway and I'm like what do you think
about marriage like when's the best time
right
all the wisdom is right there and then
one of the keys to unlocking radical
compassion for my mom is she had a
stroke and then instead of asking what
can I get what can I get what do you owe
me what should I you know trying to get
credit for taking care of you after you
had a stroke eventually my therapist was
like maybe you can use this well my
sponsor it's an opportunity for a
fact-finding mission why don't you every
time you see your mom ask her three
questions about herself like before you
came along
I literally first thing I asked her I'm
like so when did you and dad like get
engaged like what was that like he's
like she was instantly she was like
we got engaged started uh you know moved
in together planned the wedding and two
days before the wedding he decided he
didn't want to get married and we had
like you're just like wait what you had
no idea about any of this
wait what like you had bad things happen
to you
that had nothing to do with it I'm the
only victim in the world that's ever had
anything bad happen to them you know so
I started asking her questions and then
you just get more and more information
and then I find out she's her dad is
Jewish I'm like what I didn't even know
that like I gotta dig in where what part
like let me get into this ancestral [ __ ]
you know and then um
the family constellation
provider instructor
counselor with someone when they do a
thing guide
this is my OCD it serves me so I don't
want to fix it I don't know
practitioner hmm
practitioner
sure you have such a good vocabulary
so the um Family consolation
practitioner comes in asks you a bunch
of questions which by the way if anyone
answers like these questions honestly
you're going to learn a lot about
yourself it's kind of my thing with
Ayahuasca I did do Ayahuasca I have
positive things to say about it but that
said the first night I didn't really
feel anything and I was like this is
[ __ ] this is all power of suggestion
this is ridiculous like anyone sitting
on a pillow for six hours without their
phone is going to have some epiphanies
you know what I mean I think the key is
just being alone for six hours you know
and then the next night you know that
was just my ego coming up and whatever
and the next night I was able to have
you know some stuff happen but it wasn't
like my life changed you know things
just like kind of got into focus and um
and so uh
she comes over and I don't know if you
guys know this or not um I try to hide
it a little bit because it makes
everyone think I'm crazy you definitely
can't do it when you have blue hair
um which I did for quite a while which
is The Horde um the horse carriage
business uh all over this country it it
is so upsetting to me that it's like if
it's hysterical it's historical like I
tried to live in New York I can't do
things in Midtown if I hear the
carriages like I just
have like a connection like I go I I go
it's crazy that that still exists but I
feel like that's gotta be dated at this
point especially with that recent moment
of that horse collapsing and that
horrible Carriage driver that went crazy
viral like it feels like the world or at
least the internet is United around the
wrong-headedness of this Antiquated
horrible practice
I mean history will not smile kindly on
what goes on with all that yeah who
who was it that said um
a culture will be defined by how it
treated its animals uh who was that
someone I know I know this one Jamie a
senior moment yeah I don't know Jason
looked that up
um Jason call Jamie no some philosopher
or writer well what we don't realize is
that when we abuse animals we're
injuring ourself and we're screwing up
our kids so there's a psychiatrist that
I used to talk to about this of if you
are putting your kids on a horse that
it's never met putting your kid on an
elephant at the circus uh putting your
kid you know um that's what it you
always say this and it's even on your
website right like don't ride elephants
I think you always say that yeah I wrote
an elephant when I was in my early 20s
and I didn't know I think most people
don't know I think that's what's the
worst part about it that you are signing
this contract this karmic contract with
the universe and you abuse an animal and
everyone's worked so hard to convince
you that's not abuse and you're just
being a good dad or you're just being a
good mom and so you're doing something
um that is uh corroding to your own
Integrity you know some level it's wrong
when you see a bear in a cage the size
of a dog crate you know that's wrong you
know seeing a dog on a bowling ball or a
beach ball or playing basketball is you
know that's wrong on some level you know
if you were connected to your intuition
I think a lot of us are just so
disconnected from our intuition that we
can't we're that's wrong yeah you know
so that is sort of like just it's a nice
to be able to just go like
blameless blameless to everyone is like
we are moving through the world like
zombies in many ways and the animal
stuff even if you don't care about
animals or you don't have animals like
this is how offline we are this is how
autopilot we are on that we are seeing
things that should be horrific to us or
should be like oh I should protect that
thing I should help that thing that's
and we're just like here take a photo
you know that's how gone we are that's
how bad we need likes or whatever it is
I mean Instagram and social media has
been a little bit it's been a step
forward for uh animal rights in a lot of
ways because it's made more visible the
way that we just saw what happened in
New York to the carriage horse but then
in another way it's like you get so many
likes when you hold a baby tiger and you
get so many likes when you're holding it
a baby bear you know but we go okay what
is the thing that pisses off a female
tiger the most
foreign
we all know this yet if you see someone
holding a baby tiger we're like like
what do you think had to happen to the
mother sure for that to even you know we
don't even do the math you know moving
through the world and I think the thing
that is really tragic about it is this
psychiatrist who was explaining to me
that when we show our kids it is
appropriate normal even even fun to
exploit something else for our own
benefit another living thing we're
taught to abuse our power we're taught
that we're taught oh if I'm stronger
than this thing or if this thing can't
fight back I can use it It's my
prerogative that's what you're teaching
and those examples have to do with the
cuddly animals or the exotic animals but
the low-hanging fruit here like the big
the true elephant in the room is animal
Agriculture and what we do to animals
for food and even what we do to
ourselves when we use animals primarily
for food you know I'm working on this
dog food that's half crooked protein
because you know for every cow it's 260
000 gallons of water like our meat
addiction is going to put us in a
drought real fast you know so even if
you're not like animals whatever I mean
the other thing to try to you know get
people to think about it is like you're
just shortening your life as well if
that's you know in terms of you're
eating all these antibiotics you know my
dad suffered from antibiotic resistance
something that I don't feel like has
talked about that much because he had
eaten so many you know so many foods
with antibiotics jammed into them by the
time he actually needed antibiotics they
just didn't work out effective can I get
rid of that bottle that I put there like
a trash oh this person what is this I'm
so oh God embarrassing peanut butter oat
milk
so I am white that's candy and I am
that's candy I am on Medford raped in
metformin Dr Sinclair
um so back to the family constellation
thing not because I expect that you're
going to believe that this happened
um but I think you know I'm as cynical
as they come I I feel like I can tell
the story just as a comedian I'm always
the one poking holes and things I'm
always I mean even when Dr David
Sinclair came on my podcast I managed to
just embarrass myself more than normal
because he was like oh when these mice
took the NAD they ran faster and they
were stronger and you know and I'm like
well how do you assess their performance
and he's like well we just look over in
the cage and I was like well how do you
know they weren't running faster because
they were scared of you your Shadow I
mean it's pretty scary I would run and
he was like
like right it was just like what well
how do you is this how you move to the
world you know so I'm always sort of
questioning everything and um
so for this experience to be this
profound um I believe is is worth
sharing which is that um so I am I mean
debilitated by the noise of the horse
carriages seeing the horses like I
always figured oh I'm projecting onto
myself because I work too much and I
carry too much on my back and I'm
probably just projecting onto this
because I need to look to myself and I'm
going to save all these horses what I
really just need to focus on myself and
uh what's going on with me and um
I did the family constellation I'm
talking to this woman she asks questions
if you just go in because I went in like
okay of course well you Googled me so of
course you would know that well of
course you know man of course that you
know and um she asked me about my
third uh third grandfather so my grand
grand
father
and she's like what's going on there and
I was like I don't know how would you
know like nobody knows what their grand
grandparents
couldn't have been good there's no way
it was right
um and given it was like I know history
books aren't totally to be trusted
either but like I'm pretty sure that
there's some guilt and shame that I'm
carrying from that person and uh she was
like well how how are we gonna find out
what this person I was like I guess
we'll never know
already the fact that I wasn't like pick
up the phone call your uncle ask a
question what's I'm already learning
something I'm already learning a lot
about and she also uh said that um this
man's wife my grand mother used
um withholding love to punish him
and maybe that's a super common coping
mechanism but I was like
that's exactly what I do like that is
exactly exactly what I do
um and uh sometimes I Justified as I'm
just taking a break in a breather and
I'm gonna process something you know so
that I can say what I mean what I say
don't say it mean but other times I'm
just punishing and I know that about
myself and I really don't like it about
myself and the way she said it it just
was like okay I'm gonna get I'm going to
keep moving forward on this because that
was so spot on and then I call my uncle
and I'm like what's up with the great
great grandfather the great great
grandfather whatever and then he's like
oh he died of cirrhosis I'm like oh
there it is you know because she had
said he did something unforgivable and
it lives within you you know I'm like oh
yeah he drank himself to death he
probably cheated on like Gregory
grandmother which is probably pretty
normal back then but you know whatever
she would punish him by withholding love
and then he went oh yeah this is super
random but he invented this hitch that
kept horse carriages together
no way they would fall apart they would
fall apart and he invented this little
hook and in classic Cummings horrible
with money fashion uh my grandfather the
big story was he um uh in our family was
he passed on investing in McDonald's
because he said who would ever want a
dollar burger so that's
that's a good one whether apocryphal or
not like you can get a lot of mileage
out of that it was just like that's our
family so this guy uh great you know
ancestor he invented this thing but
never got credit for it never patented
it nothing you know probably an
unrecovered codependent he was like Oh
no just have it take it you know
whatever and so um that was wild I mean
I just like burst into tears when I
heard that because there was a
even if it's not true I don't know how
this all could have aligned to all feel
true but not be true you know
um I'm sure a lot of people worked in
because I said I was like I feel like a
lot of people probably worked in horse
carriages back then that was like the
main business right and he was like no
but he invented like just this thing
that made everything else actually work
and
um reduced injuries deaths of people you
know so in his mind he was doing
something great and then I guess I have
some
it's invisible I don't know how to
explain it maybe huberman can explain it
maybe some clericans but whoever maybe
you know the guy that does long path
maybe he can explain it but
it was so um it was such a relief to go
okay yes I'm just a good person that
cares about animals but also like this
is bigger than me what else that's
bigger than me am I running around with
all day just being played like a puppet
and also if he figured out how to latch
multiple carriages together for the
horse to pull he is responsible for
increasing the burden on the horse
right which maybe which at the time
informs your sensitivity around that
burden at the time probably kept people
fed you know probably did a lot of good
things back then you know and now it's
this you know disgraceful thing we do as
humans that whether we know it or not
it's it's slowly corroding our
self-worth and it's slowly corroding how
we feel about other people and at a time
where we feel quote more divided than
ever and we are more suspicious than
others than ever and we see stuff like
that you're just like what kind of
person you know it takes a toll on our
ability to be around people I think kind
of in general and um so I was like okay
yeah this is a responsibility that I've
inherited like I need to fix that thing
my ancestors did like I carried this
with me and what else am I carrying you
know it's you know when people are like
ruin a simulation I'm like yeah we're in
a simulation like we're being played by
our ancestors right that's how I like to
look at it yeah and your job is to
disentangle all of that [ __ ] and
create new healthier Pathways because if
you don't that's getting passed on to
your kid and that kid's kid so these
things will continue to play out unless
you shoulder that responsibility for
healing that and finding a better you
know kind of way and you got to do some
Recon you know and um I think for me in
terms of the connection to animals like
yes a lot of people that carry
um you know
I don't why I'm what I have a problem
with the word trauma I feel like it's
gotten like popular well it's sort of
been yeah it is it it's it's been played
out a little bit I think but
I don't know what's a better word for it
because now I feel like when I say it it
seems like I'm exaggerating because so
many people like they were out of oat
milk I am traumatized yeah so now I feel
like I'm exaggerating you know but I'm
talking about childhood sexual abuse I
think we can agree that's dramatic yes I
think we're all on the same page we
don't agree are we cool okay and I also
think trauma is appropriately you know
defined as things outside of that as
well I think people think of trauma in a
limited context that it can only be you
know sexual abuse or physical abuse Etc
but which is some of my most impactful
traumas were not any of those one of
them was
um I was in class one day and my tuition
hadn't been paid and someone came and
pulled me out of class a teacher and
said we need to talk to you your uh Bill
isn't paid I mean I was like six or
seven or something and I remember that
deep embarrassment I mean at that age
you know not understanding what was
going on and it was embarrassing and I
think that
um moving forward you know they said
said that I think it was Chris Rock that
said comedians become comedians to
control how they're embarrassed my
biggest fear in life is being
embarrassed and there's a couple things
like that that happened you know
um that I look back and I'm like that's
when it started and uh
you know so the animal thing
um you know really
was just you know as someone that from a
very early age did not trust humans or
was scared of humans didn't understand
what they wanted because when someone
hurts you in that way at that age
they're beguiling you with something
kind or nice they're confusing you and
then they're hurting you you know and
then as an adult you grow up to see
innocent voiceless things being used for
someone else's benefit just ephemerally
treating them like trash or treating
them like something just to serve them
uh that is voiceless you know horses
can't email they can't make phone calls
and I have some kind of like
thing where it's like I
I'm I go a little bit into a um
like a
what is it when you just like go offline
it's not fight flight or free like a
Fugue State maybe I go into a rage a
dissociative rage but I get very calm
like I will smash someone's window with
the dog in a hot car that's law like
it's no big deal I have the hammer in my
car it's it's it like I'm not like
reflexive it's very calm it's just in
that moment I don't remember doing it I
don't know if you saw or maybe because
you're around for the Woolsey fires
remember the giraffe so I was the girl I
was the maniac that went to get it out
oh you did WOW remember that whole like
the George I remember all the horses
went down to Zuma right on the beach
yeah yeah
and so it was just like it people were
like I was the only person driving that
truck I drove in a an electric car in a
Tesla over like five power lines that
were down I mean I look back and I'm
like it's actually just a weird miracle
that I survived that but it's not a
choice it's just kind of like I
I don't feel scared in a time of Crisis
I'm not scared of animals so there's
this deep programming inside of you that
just takes over the operating system
functions with your your conscious
decision making like offline because I
know they're scared and I can't tolerate
it like I know they know like and
they're so it's so wild that we just
have decided that animals don't have any
chance at all like we look at monkeys
and we think because it's too painful to
recognize the truth around that so it's
just a convenient rationalization to
make us feel better about our Behavior I
think and I think that it's interesting
because I you know can stop the bleeding
sometimes but kids are really the ones
that are the ones that haven't been
programmed yet that haven't been
brainwashed yet I mean Blackfish
happened because this girl was like I'm
not going there that's disgusting I'm
just crying kids now your kids know
they're like apparently then they get
they get programmed into you know a sort
of socially acceptable way of thinking
about this and then that's how you think
[ __ ] up it's very [ __ ] up that's
[ __ ] up that like even after Blackfish
like they're still like still there
hasn't been enough changes and well
people have to stop going and people
have to stop patronizing it like Chanel
didn't stop selling fur because they
loved animals you know people stop
buying it cruelty free same thing it's
just as capitalists people have stopped
buying it which brings me to something
that the horse carriage thing
is a big opportunity to practice a
modicum of empathy that I don't know
that I necessarily want this tool all
the time but I think it really helps
because a lot of the people that are
patronizing these businesses are not
Americans they're tourists and they they
have a different belief system around
animals you know and I was you know I'm
very in deep with the Korean dog meat
Festival you know and the South one the
north I
whatever's happening there
um which one is you Lynn yulin yeah
that's Korea not South Korea oh Korea
okay yeah yeah North Korea there's I
don't we don't even yeah who knows yes
ask Rogan I don't know
um but uh uh you go over there do you
have a news feed from North Korea that
we don't have or something every time he
texts me I'm like stop texting me I'm
someone's following your phone
um but uh you know I had to find empathy
like you have to find common ground with
someone so someone that is killing dogs
chopping off their feet letting you know
and then feeding them to other people
that are ordering them and eating them I
have to understand your belief system I
have to empathize with you I just have
to my dad my uncle you do you know
criminal defense attorney like I have to
find a way
to empathize with you and I
had to build that muscle because it
boils down to anyone that's poaching
elephants in Africa anyone that's
killing dogs they need money to if give
me another job that gives me as much
money and I will do it but I had someone
actually this person was um from China
from Hong Kong where I was like I just
think it's egregious the way y'all treat
animals I mean like you're pulling
gallbladders out of baby bears because
you think that it's going to be good for
your skin like what are we doing you
know Bears you know and he was like okay
well we're pretty disgusted at the way
you guys treat old people
um you know Fair Point and you're like
ah okay this is where the progress get
let's get Gnarly like let's get Gnarly
this is the way this uncomfortable
conversation that is my nightmare to
have we just made some leeway so it's
really a matter of with these poachers
and with the people to kill you have to
these horse carriage guys I can't take
away their livelihood
you can't be pro-animal and anti-human
either you know so it's like there is a
little bit of this like trying to find a
way where everybody wins because I don't
think anyone wants to abuse animals hurt
animals it means they don't have any
other choices and what's going on that
this person this was the only choice
they had and when people stand in line
to ride the horse carriages in New York
I have to go okay they have a different
value system they see horses as cars
they see horses as property you know we
put our half my families in nursing
homes
they would find that disgraceful you
know like there's a lot of epigenetics
here to unpack there's a lot of
ancestral trauma and so if there's too
much to unpack
yeah I mean you can't you can't solve
the animal problem without compassion
for the humans involved and I think
that's where a lot of advocacy you know
kind of loses sight of of the bigger
picture and actually what would be
productive and and solving the problem
as opposed to being outraged about the
problem and then also realizing that
like a little bit of a problem that we
have at the moment is not that you know
trans people are mean and you know gen
xers want everyone to be canceled and
people that abuse animals you know shoot
them in the head as soon as they have a
broken the problem is we're only hearing
from the extreme people that are not
particularly sane and uh and by saying I
just mean like don't have great bedside
Manner and aren't interested in solving
the problem or empathizing with you or
understanding why you dislike them or
why you said the thing you said and try
to understand because a lot of times
when you're going you shouldn't say that
word you're engaging in ageism we never
talk about that you know sexism
homophobe we talk about all those racism
but like expect acting you know someone
who's 60 to know that the term is now
non-binary instead of you know gender
creative or whatever that's ageist like
where would they have learned that like
that's not in the the you know Pensacola
starts to get really confusing yeah have
some compassion and go oh my God no
one's this person doesn't know any trans
people this is a person let me you know
help this person understand I don't
think this person wants to hurt me so
there's also we're not giving people the
benefit of the doubt when they you know
because there's no Nuance online or
whatever but the same thing with animal
which is part of the reason I do feel
the need to kind of talk about it
sometimes not that I come off
particularly
um well adjusted but uh a lot of animal
rescue people are have come from trauma
sexual trauma yeah aren't healed and it
turns into [ __ ] you you piece of [ __ ]
and you're a [ __ ] trash and I'm gonna
throw red paint on you on your way to
work and it's just sort of like
we haven't matured yet and healed our
wounds in order to you know engage in
this in a mature way where we're
actually solution oriented and not just
on the drug of adrenaline yeah I mean
the best way to problem solve and as you
mentioned when we were taking a break
like the best way like the best
comedians are the people who are willing
to Grapple with their wounds and engage
in the healing process right like I
think there's this idea particularly
with addicts
that it's our Brokenness that gives us
our specialness and that is our
superpower that fuels that creative
impulse or makes us special and unique
and different and the prospect of
sobriety whether it be you know
substance sobriety or emotional sobriety
is perilous because you have to break up
with that friend that you were Reliant
upon that you were convinced was the
thing that was fueling your specialness
or your talent or your comedy or
whatever it is
yes that was literally an award-winning
segue hmm
it's good right I mean that was like
unbelievable I don't think people
understand how deftly like people like
that is as a comedian watching someone
do a segue that's not and speaking of
carbohydrates uh you're just like wait
what that was masterful you're not
manipulating me are you no what for what
I'm already here okay
there's nothing else I could give you
and so um you know horses just real
quick you know animals prey animals dogs
cats all of it um I believe we are as a
species sleeping on some of the most
therapeutic tools that we have right
here horses hold up mirrors to your
behavior horses will tell you everything
about yourself that you need to know
they will tell you how you come off at
parties they will tell you what you're
you know how obvious you're who is a
good candidate for Equine Therapy so a
couple things um I also real quick let
me also talk about
um wolf wolf therapy for boys because
it's been a wolf connection right yeah
yeah my daughter we we had a birthday
party for her at Wolf connection that is
incredible was Bo there the wolf bow uh
I'm sure he was this was several years
ago
yeah oh it's okay I know that but that
was an incredible experience being there
so I don't know if they did this for you
but you know what do we call like at
risk use now like what's that called
I think it's what you just called it
kids is that what it is I mean art
is it is there a new word there's got to
be like a better word for that I'm not
like trying to get a new word I'm not
that guy but I'm just saying like kids
that um you know were in and out of
rehab in rough homes foster care kids
you know kids that just didn't have a
stable consistent
um environment and this was just boys
don't get into it with the gender thing
you do not want to do this with me
um and uh so it's just boys at risk
um
and they couldn't work with therapists
they couldn't work with you know juvie
you know social workers anything because
it was like all about being tough and
[ __ ] out I don't have any feelings and
like no man I'm hard and I'm this and
you're like okay cool there's no getting
through to this this guy has a shield up
that nothing's gonna and the more I
patronize and go like how are you
feeling the more he's gonna just shut
down and go Inward and feel
misunderstood so one of the most sort of
magical exercises we do with at-risk
youth and you know um younger kids
dealing with addiction having seen
violence in the home and such and thinks
violence is the best way to solve a
problem
which I feel like that might need to
come back that's a different story just
some just don't you feel like some
people just need once like to be hit in
the face just once sure
yeah like it's it's like you know you
got to reboot the operating system when
it starts to fragment or like this the
the little the little beach ball starts
to
spin around right when I was 11
my mom slapped me in the face I couldn't
see for like 30 seconds I had called her
a hooker
foreign
sex worker I don't know but slap me in
the face changed my life
changed my life I absolutely deserved it
and I was like got it
like that I I every day I look back on
that and I'm like thank God she smacked
me in the face like I I know how to bite
my tongue now you know but just so you
know um I think it was Mike Tyson who
said
um
it's a problem with social media is
people got used to uh talking trash and
not getting punched in the face you know
so it's just that's I say that I have
jokes yeah but like everything you can
have your plan and until you get punched
in the face yeah but I mean just people
who are just like [ __ ] you you're trash
like you're and then it's like if you
said that in person you would have been
hit in the face so you know so
everyone's a little confused about how
consequences work
um but
um
help wolves well so wolf connection you
got these kids they're you know eight
nine ten eleven twelve fourteen they've
been in rehab they've been drinking
they're in you know juvie whatever and
the uh you talk about the wolf so
there's you know ten some are crossed
with German Shepherds you know the whole
story because people fight wolves
um I was gonna make it dig of Texas but
I love you Texas my mom is from Texas
but you guys really like to keep wolves
in your basement
um and so there's all these rescued
wolves and each of them are in a
different enclosure and it's you know
you can see them all and every wolf is
doing something different one of them is
digging one of them is sort of like
moving stuff around one of them is like
sniffing under their blanket one of them
is pissing one of them is howling one of
them is just like scratching on the
fence at the other wolf one of them is
you know sleeping one of them is
you know tearing some [ __ ] up one of
them is you know hiding scared and then
um you tell everyone you know what
they're doing explain their behavior and
then you ask all the kids like who's the
alpha in this pack
and they're always like the one barking
you're like no the one Howling Man oh no
the one that's eating obviously you know
like someone that's sleeping
because when you have true power you
don't need to run around and show people
how powerful you are the best thing you
can do is just take care of yourself
like if you want to fight someone like
maybe just go take a nap like that's the
most gangster [ __ ] you can do yeah and
the confidence that all your all your
guys are gonna watch out for you exactly
exactly you know and like let people get
you like hold your space like be Regal
you know and um and so that's pretty
cool and then you go like oh this you
know this guy Beau like you know he was
taken from his mom too young and his dad
was you know never around so he's you
know more feral in this one I had a
brother that would beat up on him all
the time that's why he has half of an
ear and then you go through and you go
like which one's your favorite and
they'll be like dude I love Bo man that
goes and you're like okay so Dad stuff
like they can talk you can you can
identify what their core issue is
through which we'll figure out as long
as they get to be like a wolf you know
so like I think that we just go all
wrong about trying to communicate with
kids because we don't talk about what
they value you know we're just like
you're autistic it's like okay can I get
a metaphor to let you know what I mean
can I get a like can you put this in
terms that I either number one
understand or number two care about
um you know in terms of horses um
there's a lot there's so many incredible
benefits from Equine Therapy uh
specifically agala
e-g-a-l-e-a-g-a-l-a and Liberty training
which is basically what I do is I take
courses that were abused and make them
wild again horses whose Spirits are
broken racehorses horses that were
abused um you know dressage horses a lot
of times they use studded bits or they
put them through tunnels and scare them
and they're not allowed to roll and
they're so the idea is you can bring
them back
wow you just have to give them freedom
and treat them with respect and you can
you know my first guy it took a little
bit of time um you know because I was
still learning but horses are so patient
because they know your motive so they're
so patient with you when you screw up
they're so patient when you try too hard
you know you just for me in the
beginning I just had to say my inner
monologue out loud at all times just to
make sure I'd be like I'm insecure that
you don't like me and now you're walking
away why would you walk away and smell
poop like poop is better than me like
why do you like poop more than you like
me and then I'm kind of going like what
kind of maniac is trying to compete with
a animal's desire to smell poop like
that's just not me respecting this
animal's nature and ancestry which
sometimes we do with human beings too
all the time men and women kids adults
whatever so it was sort of like oh God I
really need other people to behave a
certain way in order to be comfortable
that's bad news yeah because 95 of the
time nobody acts the way I want them to
so I better figure out a way to feel
comfortable without really like hammers
home that lesson inside job dude and um
and also also you know we do with like
young girls guys need it too but the
whole deal with horses is they will test
you constantly to see how much
self-respect you have they want to see
like What You're Made Of they want to
see how much because they want you to
like yourself they want you to be
confident they want you to be Regal so
they'll test you and they'll test you
and then you'll see people going stop
stop you're like okay let's talk through
why that was how you were going to solve
that problem
like in general doesn't work why did
that horse even think it could get that
close to you like why did you even allow
it in your space at all you know well
it's just depending you start moving and
then it okay right I see who you are I
can you know so we take these energy
extenders they're not whips and
basically girls learn like no you have
to say it
the same what your energy has to matter
if you can't go no your communication
has to be Congress right to get the
result you want and clear affirmative
and like flexing a healthy boundary with
honesty that Garner's respect correct
but it starts here and like you
mentioned boundaries earlier and we
never got to them but just the idea
boundaries aren't for them they're for
you and if someone violates your
boundary you don't set another boundary
you remove yourself from the situation
that's a personal boundary you know so
if I say no to the horse no to the horse
and I'm being clear and it still is
going to disrespect me I just remove
myself entirely and then we can start
start again later because you got your
consequence and let's see if we can
coexist you know so it's like because we
don't realize how much you know isn't it
70 of communication is non-verbal but we
only focus on that 30 of just words
[ __ ] [ __ ] like words are just
[ __ ] you know and so it's such a
healing experience to be around animals
and just go oh that's why that person I
never got along because I was like how
are you doing how is everything like I'm
confusing because this I learned to be a
confusing communicator and horses only
deal with like Clarity um and then also
just
you know I mean the things I've learned
just I mean you go on and on I mean even
about your breath you know because they
are attuned to breath so if I'm like
they're gone dude right because that's
how you breathe if you're scared your
amygdala shut off so when you're I know
humans I'm sure come on done a billion
times you know uh of like the energy so
a lot of people come into their office
and they're like why is why is everyone
in such a bad mood you take responsible
for your energy and how contagious it is
you know energy contagion is so real and
when watching a horse when it's around
ugly energy or energy that doesn't serve
them that's depleting or confusing just
removes itself that was a tool that I
didn't even know existed yeah like it
didn't even occur to me you could just
like leave if someone wasn't you didn't
have to keep talking you know just get
up and go you know I didn't even know
that was an option I thought it was like
you get on the dance floor and you're
dancing until your partner gets off like
just go sit on the bench when in doubt
get off the dance floor what are you
doing you know so working with horses
there's there's no more rewarding
relationship than having a personal one
with a horse because you really know
your value
um and you really they keep you
accountable on a daily basis can't stay
clean on the shower you took yesterday
so it's like yesterday with the best
time and he trusted me so much and he
invited me to get on his back and we ran
around and then you walk by the next day
while he's eating he looks up and I was
like hi you're like I thought we had
right didn't we have a thing earn it
again I gotta earn it again how many do
you have you have your own horses or do
you go somewhere else like are you
actually teaching this or what is the
situation that I have is this um
wonderful girl uh Genevieve air she's a
Gala and Liberty instructor she works
with um kids on the Spectrum and such um
you know kids on the Spectrum have
incredible gifts when it comes to being
able to communicate non-verbally with
animals it's so amazing to see and it's
so amazing to watch a kid who people are
always like what do you want I can't
understand what you want what did you
ever do and the horses just like got it
and they're just simpatico and this and
they found the person that understands
them it's the most incredible thing like
you're not broken you're actually just
you're like hyper intuitive you know so
that's really cool to see
um you know I don't I basically will
rescue the horse I'll do the um Liberty
training there's also this is getting
you know very granular there's a uh
practice called being with horses as a
German woman
um it's I can send you the Kindle link
about how to have an equal relationship
with horses where you're basically have
a 50 50 relationship that's based in
respect and you can have such you can do
such cooler things with a horse because
horses when they want to communicate
with you they start to mimic you so I'll
like jump over a jump and he'll jump
over a jump and I'll do this and he'll
jump up in the air you know it's like
it's the coolest thing in the world
um to be able to get to that point but
rescuing them getting new one I mean
it's just my Kink I just I'm like I love
it so much it's just beautiful they're
just they have eternal wisdom I mean
they have eternal you know they know
when it's gonna rain they they there's
this famous
um story about a horse and I think it
was Virginia that wouldn't go under uh
Bridge wouldn't go under a bridge
they're beating it they're beating it
wouldn't go under a bridge and the next
morning it collapsed I mean they just
have all this and we're just sitting on
all this wisdom we're were just like
running the other direction away from
mirrors dog training same thing you know
people go if oh I'd rescue this Dog and
Its Behavior is it what I want I'm going
to return it it's like you're missing
the opportunity to learn so much about
yourself
from training this dog so that's why I
also love getting Foster dogs and
training them because I always learn so
much about my lack of patience about my
need I want to give you a treat because
I want to make you like me
Dill I'm still doing this
I'm still doing this I had my ear bitten
off by a dog you know I knew what to I
Knew not to do that but I conflated love
and pity which is a huge thing that
codependents do and I was like oh my God
I'm gonna let him sleep in the bed with
me which is a dominant Behavior letting
a dog lick your face or be in the bed
with you and it had been taken from its
mom too young and their mouth is their
hands so I got down to play with it one
day and it just bit my ear off not out
of aggression just impersonal nothing
nothing personal they're just made of
knives and that was my fault and I think
it's really cool to work with animals
because they won't do or say anything
that will make you so mad that it's easy
to blame so if you and I have like a
rough conversation and we're both kind
of wrong and the way we handled it you
know because we went to our trauma
response I was like well if you hadn't
had an office all the way out here and
then all of a sudden we're both [ __ ]
with horse animals you're always the
[ __ ] and that's such a great
opportunity you can't give no one to
blame right
which is like kind of the best thing
ever because you don't have to spend all
this time wondering whose fault it was
it was yours do you how many animals do
you keep in your house then you rescue
them and then get them to other places
or you'd have like a menagerie running
around it depends on who's asking if
animal control I have three hmm
um but I have um I I take no one's list
if they saw that I'm on they're
definitely not listening they're so sick
we'll just beep it
no I have um a revolving door
um of animals I have four dogs
four dogs are you being honest no no I
do I this is you know what because it's
it's just too boring there's a lot of
dogs that I've rescue and I still pay
for their medical care but they live
with other people and they have
wonderful lives and stuff so to me
rehabilitating an animal is always so
therapeutic for me you know everyone's
like you're such a hero I'm like I get
way more out of it than the animals you
know so I do these you know there have
been a couple Dodo videos where I've
rescued dogs that were just oh cool
really like three broken legs and learn
to you know they remind me how
resilient we are because dogs when they
have you know two broken legs or missing
legs they're just like let's [ __ ]
party like they don't let it stop them
and I'm like what's my excuse yeah it's
always inspiring those Dodo videos of
dogs that are or all kinds of animals
doing cool stuff that girl was from high
school was mean to me at the reunion so
I'm gonna just
totally regress into a petty [ __ ] like
this is this dog had three legs and I
was like let's go to that page like what
like why do you and they're so confused
when you feel sorry for them they don't
want to be pity you know so I think uh
yeah and I think watching Dodo videos I
think that's also a tool like I think
scheduling positive content
is key you know watch one dodo video a
day you know what people are awesome
when you see a guy jump in a river to
save a dog like it's it really helps
balance out the Twitter mob everyone's a
psycho now yeah I love the dodo
I have I think three Dodo videos because
I had a pig that I rescued
um uh a Sharpay that was uh it was in a
cro like it was in a crime so it can't
be adopted out so I sometimes take dogs
that are evidence in a crime
um so that they can't be you know taken
back like exotic animals so exotic and
this is also part of the reason that
I've learned so much about the Exotic
Animal trade and it's
I wish my nightmares on no one but
usually when there's you know uh lions
tigers bears being trafficked there's
also a lot of exotic dogs like this was
an albino Sharpay I get a pharaoh dog
um and then often this is the main main
main main main main main main reason
that I have no compassion for animal
abusers is because
um anyone who's abusing an animal is
almost always there's no chance that
sure they don't go inside take a dog not
hit their kid or their wife or whatever
so the dog or the animal is just a
socially acceptable type type of abuse
like when you go in the door it's gonna
you know continue and also when people
um traffic exotic animals humans are
always in the truck as well so it's like
if you see a tiger in someone's backyard
chances are there's oh they're weird
something else going on yeah yeah for
sure so it's like just it's all the same
stuff it's arms dealers uh traffickers
Psychopaths you know animals the whole
deal so it's like it's pretty it gets
pretty dark pretty quick yeah and I'm
like it's kind of my dream to just like
hunt these people
because there's something I I but that's
a superpower I have I am not scared of
the things most people are scared of I'm
scared of like eye contact being like
Damian Mander do you know Damien Mander
no oh we'll talk afterwards but he he
was uh special forces dude
um who had a lot of Trauma from you know
being in combat Etc and you know
basically
you know became aware of what was going
on with exotic animal trade in parts of
Africa and he was like [ __ ] these guys
and he basically went there with all of
his skills and was like I'm gonna end
this problem and now he's created this
militia that's all women I think it's
called the Akasha there's a little
documentary about it I'll send it to you
um to really kind of police poaching in
their native territories he didn't
unbelievable I had talked you know what
I'm talking about I know him yeah and
the tricky part about that is like it's
really is like we can go stop the
bleeding stop the bleeding but until we
talk to the guy and the demands and and
the demand and also governments there
actually give you my a lot of it is a
nuisance you know there was an amazing
article that a woman an African woman
wrote I think was about remember when
that guy shot that lion
which guy
lots of guys shoot lions like I mean it
was like famous he was
um
um
I shot a lot like he was whole he was
like a politician or something he shot a
lion and it kind of went viral and
people started talking about trophy
hunting for two years you know and a lot
of people
um you know don't understand that lions
are a very real nuisance in Africa and a
woman wrote a piece that said why we
don't cry for Lions you know because
every time our kids leave the house we
worry about them so I'm the first person
I have coyote dens all over my property
and you know I have you know a little
water station for them they have
everything they need but if they come
for my animal they're it's a wrap you
know so if you're if you're in America
and you're like who what's the one
animal that you'd kind of be fine with
us I mean the coyotes dude [ __ ] those
things you know because they are not
wired uh they are well not wired to
attune to us to serve us nothing and I
know if it's between me going you're a
little in killing my dog they'll kill it
you know so they also see it as that I'm
not killing a lion I'm just protecting
my children and you can't get between
that you know and so
um it's like you know it's really about
changing laws kind of the more boring
stuff of going and going like why are
these poachers getting like a stipend
for doing this why are they getting tax
breaks for doing this oh because it
makes it easy for you guys to spend less
taxes on cleaning up all the crop
destruction or the police force we have
to hire to deal with this or whatever
you know it's solving a problem for them
in some in some way and then also why
don't you have the kind of economy where
these people can actually have jobs that
doesn't include that well that's the big
thing if there was a better option they
would take it as well they would take it
so I'm always thinking how do we horse
carriage people it's like these people
have been doing this for 30 years they
own this horse you just take their you
know like you're taking their livelihood
from them we have to replace the
livelihood so it's not now their only
option in life so that's like
the kind of activism that actually gets
stuff done instead of just like [ __ ] you
and then moving on with your dad like
that just makes people think animal
people are crazy thanks for that so I
know you loved my my my segue my
transition but then I don't feel like we
we segued into
wait what was it I thought you wanted to
talk about comedy no so because we gotta
get out of here I know but I don't want
to I want to end the longest I I know I
think it might be no I think we did I
did a four hour one once but we're
getting close to that
um because I think I was trying to go to
like horses really help you look in the
mirror well I think the idea was yeah
like like just the Journey of like of
self-healing and like becoming an
integrated whole person
um and how that actually allows you uh
to flourish in a way that feels
antithetical to what you might think it
is
and to kind of like maybe round this out
with some thoughts on on that because I
think people are really afraid hey it's
scary to tackle the things that
um you don't want to look at in yourself
and there is that fear that if you do
that
um then you're going to be this
different person and you're going to
lose whatever it is that you feel like
makes you you and allows you to do you
in the world like I'm gonna lose what
makes me a cocaine addict what would
possibly God forbid I change any of this
precious programming
um just something real quick uh that you
said about
um
you know looking at yourself and then
accepting it Etc and something uh that
is a miracle about 12-step programs that
will get into comedy 12-star programs
really taught me say the most disgusting
thing you thought to do today
and you will destroy in this room you
know so also that practice of telling
someone your deepest darkest secret
telling someone I just did cocaine 400
you know grams of it last week or
whatever and they still hang out with
you right yeah so you have the data of
like I can acknowledge all these parts
of myself and people won't leave they
won't think I'm disgusting they won't
think I'm trash you know and then to go
on stage and talk about it have people
laugh and then pay you is the ultimate
way to sort of heal all that Shame about
your thoughts and the way it's like I
can use this for something you know and
that's how I took God sorry like my
power back you know I was like wait a
second maybe all of the worst things
about me
will like help other people talking
about it will like help other people you
know and it forces me to tell the truth
because I came from an environment where
it was just like everything was a lie
I'm I'm five minutes out you're not you
are an hour away and we're jumping in
the shower no you're not little lies big
lies all of it and you can't lie to an
audience whose reaction is involuntary
you know you can perform for your own
fans to get clapter and stuff but
everyone knows what that is you know you
get a because as someone that was so
obsessed with dishonest feedback no you
look great no I'm fine like I only
believe in involuntary reaction so if
someone laughs or doesn't laugh they're
right you know and that is that is very
and that's something you really can't
fake that makes me feel so I can fake a
couple other things but that's a
different conversation
um but uh
it's really soothing to just be able to
believe everyone
to just believe whatever like no one's
kissing your ass no one like it's just
great everything you guys just did
whether I liked it or not is true and
that is like the best feeling in the
world but you also have to tell the
truth you know and I think that after I
spent time you know with animals my
whole life and learning like truth is
the most important way that you can
maintain self-esteem he's just telling
the truth the absence of secrets so we
always say you know like we're only as
sick as the secrets we keep
it took me so long
to take that adage seriously and I
cannot believe how it changed my life it
was like uh taking steroids or something
it was just like I was twice as
successful I was twice as happy in my
relationships but people liked me twice
as much just because I was like
telling the truth
um and not in a trying to um
not patronizing them with lies because
they can't handle that I'm going to be
late they'll be fine look at their phone
whatever and next time leave 15 minutes
earlier [ __ ] selfish brat
um and so it felt like kind of a natural
uh sort of projection there I think for
me however being a stand-up comedian I'm
going to be really honest I think that a
lot of it came was my wiring and then
some things that I guess you would maybe
categorize as traumas
um in terms of I was alone so much you
know and when someone was around you had
to make them laugh right away to keep
their attention you know if they're
drinking they're socializing they're
doing compulsive behaviors like you bet
you have a minute to get this person's
attention or to get this laugh or this
is your only opportunity to get some
self-esteem today or be seen you know
and you got to move fast also I think
that
I'm not going to be the person to
spearhead this but
our names are a big part of why we are
who we are what we're named you know I
mean your name is Rich right
that worked out yeah Rich roll rock and
roll dick roll yeah you know like and
then my mom's maiden name is spindle and
and uh did she come from her brother was
Dick spindle what hello dick spindle
yeah
how about that your uncle should have
married Whitney Cummings well I could
have if we got married and I took your
name it would be dick Cummings
about that
well do you want better my parents
before they got married my mom's last
name was coming in his as comings she
was Paddy coming Cummings no way so had
I taken her last name
you'd be dick coming
which is even better because that's the
verb not the now yeah that's better but
this thing I was always so embarrassed
about I didn't realize you know that it
was funny until much later but I was
made fun of constantly I mean it's just
like the best way to bully someone you
know when you come in your mouth come on
your face I would get my like test
papers back in school where my name
Whitney coming someone scribbled it out
[ __ ] on your mouth in your like it was
just constant so I had to find a way to
joke about it I had to find a way to uh
embarrass myself first to own the
bullying you know to make fun of myself
because I know they're gonna make fun of
this name so I think that your name has
a really big part of your character in a
lot of ways I think a lot of really
successful people have really
complicated names
have you noticed that because they've
had to constantly correct people they've
had to count there's a theory I'm
working on please tell me if I'm wrong
but when you see those people that are
like hi my name is Aardvark
McMahon de Swan and you're like Aardvark
no it's Aardvark like you have to claim
your space you have to stand up you have
to make sure you know you develop
confidence that way you know and so you
know I think my name definitely got me
uh thinking in terms of you better be
funny all the time you better think yeah
well it sounds like your dad was funny
and always was wanting to engage with
you on that my dad was so funny he would
pick me up from school and would usually
be late but didn't matter
um later uh he would um I don't know if
you ever saw
um Three Amigos
I mean forever the movie I wouldn't
remember it's one of my I just have the
visual image of those guys sitting
around a campfire
uh night Ned
what that's what he said good night mad
I don't even know the bat said it yeah
but there was um a moment where it was
Steve Martin was up on a billboard and
they were trying to do some furtive
Heist and uh Martin Short and Chevy
Chase were looking for him and couldn't
find him and Steve Martin goes look up
here look up like he was trying to be
discreet about it and it's such a dumb
moment and he's like look up here look
up here look trying to do bird sounds to
get him to look and then finally he goes
hey guys like it's so stupid but I knew
my dad was there because I would just
hear look over here and my dad I didn't
know where he was he'd be like hiding
behind a car you know he's just like
every moment was an opportunity to make
people laugh every single moment he just
he he didn't understand the point of
engaging with someone if you weren't
asking them questions about themselves
or he always said to me he's like
um there's no point in ever disliking
anyone if you don't like someone it just
means you haven't asked them enough
questions about themselves you know he
always it was annoying when I was a kid
but now it's it's served me so well
anyone he would meet where are you from
man oh Cincinnati oh yeah down on the
and then I don't even know if he had
been all these places or not but he
would always be like what's the best
what's that burrito place and they'd be
like ah Mama's breeders yes like he
would just always trying to connect
always trying to make people's day and
it was always people that you know
waitresses janitors whatever you know
and and um I didn't even realize what a
gift that was but
something that he used to do to me and I
think that I didn't realize this until
very recently the pandemic I had a
couple you know thank God that wasn't
totally wasted I had a couple
breakthroughs in terms of going I'm
going to radically forgive my parents
let me just turn everything into a
positive and I remember this is the way
we used to study so he would um have the
textbook I'm trying to really talk fast
uh he would have a textbook and he would
say okay say all the the date of the
Civil War the date uh the Amer the
American Indians you know came over they
were called that then
you know the date of the
Spanish-American War the data and then I
would have like have it so I had to say
it backwards and four it's
Spanish-American more date
um Civil War Spanish American war you
know like he would throw me curveballs
and stuff like that and then he closed
the book and then he'd go
I mean how do we know the book is right
I mean there's no way this is all right
I mean this was just some like hearsay
like some guy was like hey I think the
Civil War started like a pro and then he
would basically say question everything
you need to learn it all to pass the
test but question all of this wow you
know and so I think that's part of what
formed me which is which is really the
comedian's Mantra right question
everything and I don't have this you
have this obsession with human
psychology behavior and all of that too
and into it we we can't stop until
something makes sense you know and I
think it's very much like trying to
figure out what people meant When We
Were Young we had to we everything had
to add up you know Neil Brennan always
says it's an obsession with Justice
which I think is a great way to look at
it
um and I always like to say that
comedians say something that isn't true
and then they prove it
um
comedians say something that isn't true
and then prove it the jokes right so you
know and then also it's like like uh
you're a lawyer basically you're
defending a criminal idea you know I
have a bit my last special where it's
like I think we need to get rid of
ballet ballet's bat hear me out and then
I gotta dig myself out of the hole but
the jokes that the things you haven't
heard of yeah yeah you know and then I
have to defend my point which is the
most fun thing in the world having
someone go that's a ridiculous idea I'm
never gonna side with you and then just
slowly like get them to change their
minds you know I think that's what's so
fun about stand up is like you get to
get like someone to think critically
about something that they maybe have
never thought about before you know I
think the great comedians do that they
get you to look at something that you're
for granted completely differently right
question everything yeah question
everything
memorize the textbook first then
question everything do you think
anything we learned in school is I mean
I was with my niece she's 15. I don't
know she we were doing her homework I
was like I don't remember I didn't know
oh they were right oh they erased that
they realized that was I mean I'm like
when I was a kid I learned the Native
Americans and the pilgrims had a
wonderful meal together right yeah that
was that was the extent of it they had a
party they wore the buckle shoes like
they had a great time they had a
plethora what is it panoply cornucopia
the Plenty the Horn of Plenty
exactly they just hung out they traded
blankets it's
you know so it's you know who knows but
but I'm so grateful for that and that's
some I remember people saying like why
is your dad making like making you chat
like it at the time I thought it was
wrong it's like I'm the kid in school
going like yeah but was that really true
but like are you sure it happened that
way and I was seemed annoying and crazy
you know but it was like okay this is
the only profession I can really do
because I get my OCD gets so intense I
think about something so intensely you
know Louis C.K always says if you think
about something more than three times a
week you gotta just write about it right
well I want to get into like how the
writing process works and how that all
happens but we're gonna have to we're
gonna have to do that on a different day
stay tuned we're now we're now like well
into longest podcast ever terrain
territory podcaster which I'm good with
I'm the ultra endurance athlete I'm cool
with all of it yeah because I need a
plunge yeah I know really quickly really
quick the supplements you take on a
daily basis oh geez I mean it varies I
mean I take athletic greens I take promo
code uh yeah I take I take vitamin D I
take B12
um but if you're going to be outside in
the sun do you still take vitamin D I do
uh my D levels are fine but
from what I understand even being out in
the sun a lot you can still be deficient
most people are vitamin D deficient you
had to send your butthole yeah oh right
what is it called I don't know perennial
Sunny
are you into that no
all right we're going off the rails I
know I know I just was dying to know
thank you for having me cool thank you
wonderful to finally meet you that was
super fun what a pleasure sorry I kept
you guys so long come back and do it
again sometime
um check out Whitney's podcast good for
you the new uh the new special it's
called jokes on Netflix no politics no
politics yes appeals to everyone I just
I it's our job to bring people we can
talk about your special or anything I
feel bad why what happened here is this
bad no I feel like you're
how do we do just you decide
really
Giselle Giselle likes it I'm really
happy I wanted to talk about mental
health that's what we talked about how
do you feel honestly
it's good I don't have feelings you
don't I'm kidding I'm gonna look to you
to decide how I should feel no I I feel
like we were honest and not rushing
excuse me not rushing to get to anything
no you know it was good I think it was
the best comedy
people hate us now I mean I don't think
so no we need you we need you more than
ever
um but we should get to that yeah maybe
next time because I do think everyone
should do stand up at some point even if
they only do it once even if you just
set up a little room at your office and
do it with some co-workers it will
change your life yeah it's very scary if
somebody said you can go skydiving or
get up and do stand up that's that's a
toss-up for me no way yeah
for sure see that is fascinating to me
that's why I think everyone should do it
once
I think you'd be surprised yeah it's
like a great thrill and you learn so
much about yourself and everyone needs
to be public speaking now whether you're
given presentations any field you're in
yeah it's a skill that I think if
everyone had they'd be a little less
anxious all the time all right well
we'll explore that more next time cheers
thanks Whitney unless you're a
younger prettier girl than me please
don't start stand up because I'm already
terrified
please nip it in my heels
[Music]